e
good morning it's now a little bit after
10 o'clock we're going to get underway
uh in the house Judiciary Committee and
uh we'll start with the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge of alleg to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God
indivisible liy and justice for
all thank you and uh we'll now open a
public hearing on Senate Bill
314 and recognize Senator Susi to
introduce the
Bill thank you very much representative
Smith um good morning um Senator
chandley the prime sponsor apologizes
that she couldn't be with you this
morning uh but I am here on her behalf
uh to present Senate Bill 314 I'm Donna
Susi I represent Senate District 18
comprised of five Wards in the city of
Manchester and the town of
Lichfield um Senate Bill 314 provides a
comprehensive solution to some of the
challenges facing the department of
corrections as it fulfills its
responsibility to conduct competency
hearings it aims to incentivize
attendance mitigate problems created
when people fail to show for their exams
and provides a mechanism for dismissing
charges with cases deemed
nonrestorable this legislation is the
product of a collaboration by many
parties um but particularly it's the
work of experts from the Department of
Corrections who I believe are
represented here today with input and
suggestions from the AC you and criminal
defense attorneys um I would ask you to
look favorably upon this um legislation
as I said I believe there are folks here
from the Department that can speak to
the more technical aspects of how the um
competency hearings are conducted and I
testony and be happy to answer any
questions um but certainly would defer
if if they are more technical in nature
very good any questions for Senator
Susi seeing none thank you thank you
very much we now call relle Barb and
Jane Graham from New Hampshire
Department of
Corrections good morning uh for the
record my name is Jane Graham I'm the
Strategic Communications administrator
for the Department of Corrections and
with me is Dr relle Barb she's the chief
forensic examiner for the office of
forensic
examiners
um thank you for uh listening to us on
um in our support of SB
314 this as Senator Susi said before was
a collaborative effort we when it was
introduced um by Senator Chanley and we
had our first hearing there were a
couple of concerns that were expressed
by the ACLU and the New Hampshire
Association of defense attorneys during
that time so we were able to sit down as
a group and collaboratively work on
those differences together um and I
think that the the product here is is a
great bill that we can all agree on I
also just wanted to add that uh the
commissioner Hanks was sorry that she
couldn't be here this morning but she is
at a funeral um otherwise she would have
been here to testify um and then I'm
going to let Barb speak to a lot of the
technical um pieces of the office FR
examiners um she is by far the expert so
I'm going to turn it over to her no
pressure uh good morning could you
repeat what your title is I sure I'm the
Strategic Communications administrator
whatever that means thank you sorry I
handle all the legislation and all the
internal and external Communications for
the Department thank
you good morning I am Dr Barb I am the
chief of the office of the forensic
examiners um and I am here to speak in
support of SB
314 um so the Department of Corrections
uh contracts with Wexford Health sources
um for all of the positions that are
filled at the office of the forensic
examiners the office of forensic
examiners began in the early 2000s
around that time with one examiner and
one administrative support person over
the time all our numbers of evaluation
requests increased uh at some point we
were at three forensic evaluators
currently we are staffed uh funded for
one Chief forensic examiner uh
4.8 uh examiners forensic examiners and
two administrative staff positions at
this time we have uh two vacant uh
forensic evaluator positions and one
vacant administrative position
the increase in competency evaluations
is something that's not unique to New
Hampshire the need has been driven um by
several different factors Across the
Nation and so we just as every other
state have had an increase in those
numbers that's put a strain on the
amount of experts that we have in these
areas to work so we continue to um to
look to other states to uh network with
graduate school programs for forensic
psychologists to recruit um for
in-person State inate evaluators at this
time uh we have uh we kind of pivoted
and we had hired some uh remote
evaluators from out of state who are
forensic evaluators to assist in um
filling those two positions that we have
open the SB 314 um hits on a couple of
issues that we have at the of um we have
a backlog of cases those cases came um
slowly over time and then a little
faster um in about
2001 we saw an increase to over 800
orders whereas prior to that we were
only getting 500 to 600 orders a year um
So within the last um since 2001 we've
averaged
836 evaluations oh sorry
2021 2021 we've averaged 836 orders
which is roughly about a 20% increase
the other challenge that we do have is a
high no-show rate um part of that is
because of the population that we serve
um several are unhoused um mental health
problems substance abuse problems but
that still is a high no-show rate and
when that occurs um we have prepared and
the evaluator is there and that time is
is is wasted in that sense although we
do other tasks um but it also then
produces another court order because
that goes back to the court and they
re-refer the individual back so that is
also part of the increase in orders that
we've seen is that high no-show rate
which averages about
30% um and um so that's kind of why we
address this this bill so SB 314 creates
incentives for individuals to appear for
court order evaluations it allows an
extension of the time frame for
evaluations to be done if the individual
fails fails to appear or if we are uh if
we fail to be provided with the records
that we need that I'll speak to in a
moment um and the hope is that by
reducing that no-show rate it will
increase our efficiency by allowing us
to see those cases and will then um
decrease the amount of orders that we're
getting because of those repeat orders
that we have when someone no shows
um additional language emphasizes that
in an instant when an
individual is not competent and not
restorable and that is something that is
is obvious to the court that it
reinforces what already is existing
legal Authority for them to dismiss the
charges with out Prejudice so this in
314 what we aim to do was to instill
that confidence that they would be be
able to dismiss those charges um in
those straightforward cases in which the
court feels confident in making that
call um the other important part which
is very important to me as a a forensic
examiner is the issue of Records um
often we have uh difficulties getting
medical educational and mental health
records for multiple reasons in 314 we
addressed um that
the uh court is allowed to order those
records with for the last three years
and additionally if we find that we need
them for any reason that those can be
ordered to be delivered to us medical
mental health and educational records
are important because they allow us to
conduct and inform a valid and reliable
Report with opinions for the court to
make their decisions which is what our
goal is they contain a rich history of
someone's mental health and medical
history that lets us see the traj Tory
and the symptoms for Diagnostic purposes
for intervention purposes they
illuminate what medications they are and
those factors can impact um mental
status factors and their ability to
participate in their defense and make
decisions about their cases beyond that
the medical records inform their medical
conditions that may be impacting
impacting their competency related
abilities they also serve to either
confirm or contest the symptoms or the
experiences that the individual is
reporting to us which are also very
important and all of those contribute to
us being able to offer the judges
informed valid and reliable opinions
regarding competency to proceed and
restorability and dangerousness which
are the three things that we're tasked
to address under
13517 so those are the main pieces that
I wanted to cover for 314 um I we are
currently
um uh I wanted to make clear that the
Department of Corrections is the entity
that's currently funded to support these
forensic evaluations under the office of
forensic
examiners we take our job very seriously
at the of we know that it is an
important task um that quality
evaluations are important for the legal
process and for the courts and for the
individuals that we are serving as well
so I want to thank you all for
considering um my comments today and if
if you have any questions I will be
happy to try to answer them for you yes
uh representative Smith thank you very
much thank you for your your testimony
when you say um that you that there's
difficulty sometimes getting the records
and this gives you the
power or some power to to get those
records where are the
records so when uh evaluations are
ordered um the the uh defense Council
the defendant the defendant is the one
that holds the power to their medical
records mental health records um so
those records are uh sometimes
provided by defense Council and the
defendant sometimes for some reason
though that permission does not get is
not given by the defendant for multiple
reasons or we are not provided with them
from defense Council for multiple
reasons this allows the court the power
to order those records in all of the
cases so that they have to be provided
to the office of forensic
examiners what oh follow up of course
yes
is what comes to mind and this is
probably the wrong thing to come to mind
so you straighten me out please is
something along the lines of self
incrimination um as why why wouldn't the
defense or the why wouldn't not the
defense why wouldn't those records be
provided so um incompetent uh
self-incrimination is protected um um so
when an individual meets with me for
competency evaluation while not the
information is not confidential we do
not speak to anything that could be
incriminating in any way
um and my report is only to be used to
address the competency issues it is not
to be used in any further trial
processes I am not called to testify any
further it is limited and sealed to that
competency
evaluation um defense Council um is
tasked with defending their client and
so if their client does not want those
records for released for any reason um
defense Council um
in those cases will not readily give
those records this allows the court to
order those records to be given to us
not to other parties but to the doctor
who is doing the evaluation to inform
the
court does that answer your question Mr
chair yes representative D Lorenzo and
then representative H uh thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
I just feel like we need to back up a
little bit I I I don't really understand
how a person um is scheduled for a
competency hearing is that um certainly
is that for all um no no so um
competency is raised um it's an ethical
obligation for uh attorneys to raise
competency if they have any concerns
that their client um does not understand
the legal proceedings be it the legal
system the charges that are brought
against them and also it is their right
that they have the ability to assist
Council in mounting their defense so um
in those cases competency is raised so
the cases in which competency are raised
are those that where the individual has
a mental health history often we see
that it is raised when um substance uh
substance issues come in um as council
is not an expert in whether or not these
are limited substance in educed uh
mental health symptoms that they're
having but if they cannot communicate
with our client to make those decisions
they're going to raise competency um and
the and and legally they can
everything's put on hold they cannot
proceed until the individual is stable
and able to assist in their defense and
understand what's going on during the
legal
proceedings uh well first representative
orgon and then representative uh CH
please yes I'm um specifically and I
suppose you deal with this issue already
but like what's on page two
about um e the course show are all
medical and mental health and
educational record past three years be
provided um we're dealing with a
population who at a minimum are in legal
trouble and have mental health issues
their life is probably also chaotic in a
lot of other ways so how who's supposed
to round round up these records and
Supply them probably most of the people
do not have a neatly ordered file
cabinet in their office with like all
these things in chronological order so
how do you get get hold of these records
and what is it and again like what do
you and then which what is that you're
looking for the records so there are two
different ways that um that records are
obtained um a lot of times defense
counil um right off the bat will have
their clients sign release forms and
they will send them out to the different
facilities that they are aware that they
did have treatment or may have had
treatment um the second part is that a
court order um so the court orders that
those records be released directly to
the office of forensic examiners and the
court order is sent directly to the
facilities so a lot of times we'll know
from the interview where the
individual's been treated or we'll have
a good idea um and so we'll send off
those releases to get those
records representative
Kat
just a question on the the language here
so this is stating that the court shall
order that all medical mental health and
educational records from the last three
years we provided to the forensic
examiner wouldn't it be better to say
may order that way the court is
determining whether or not the record
should be sent because there may be
medical records which are completely
unrelated to the mental health status
that might be otherwise private that the
person may not
want to be aired so to speak so the
reason that we say all mental health
records and medical records and
educational records for the last three
years is that we will review them um and
we will determine what is relevant to
the question um and what is not relevant
so these records are not turned over to
the court process uh what is relevant is
provided in the report as a summary um
in forensic evaluations we're speaking
to answering the question and as
psychologists um
we understand the importance of
confidentiality but in the mental health
process in the medical process um but at
the same time we need to be able to form
a a valid opinion regarding whether or
not this individual has a mental disease
or defect whether or not there is
treatment that can restore them and th
that information we need in order to
make those opinions so um it is standard
practice as part of a of any kind of
psychological evaluation that we look at
all available evidence that is
interviewing um collateral resources as
well so calling friends calling family
calling neighbors um calling previous
clinicians um it's pretty standard
practice for evaluations and as I said
allows us to not only have a a rich
history but a timeline of the symptoms
and the onset the medications that
they're on how they present with
different individuals if someone's
complaining of memory issues for example
um are those memory issues being seen by
other individuals in other settings that
is also important for the court to know
and important for whether or not they
have a mental disease or defect which is
the question we need to answer first
represent excuse me representative
Manos okay so other questions rep
representative dorenzo thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my my
question so are there cases where the
behavior of the person who's going to
court automatically triggers um an
evaluation for instance if it's like a
you know just a horrible horrible
criminal
type um
thing so anyone can raise competency um
at any point uh during the legal process
so we sometimes will have if the
behavior is concerning in a court
hearing that the the the judge will
raise the issue and request a competency
evaluation I've had it where um
prosecutors have also raised um had a
conversation um in lower level incidents
violations or misdemeanor bees and they
have raised the concern because legally
and ethically they need to raise that
concern so sometimes it is the behavior
that they see sometimes times it comes
from discussions that uh are attorney
client privileged conversations and
during the course of that discussion
they realize that the client may not be
in touch with reality or they may be so
severely depressed and suicidal that
they don't even care to take part in the
legal process um and so that is when
they will raise it and they will say we
can't move forward your honor my my
client cannot make decisions about how
they want to proceed in any in a
rational
manner you're welcome uh yes
representative trip sorry thank you
chair thank you for taking my
question the uh it seems that the the
majority of the changes deal with
non-incarcerated
people
or I don't know what the proper term is
nowadays uh are there any issues with
the uh people that are incarcerated
so the the records are still an issue
for those that are um incarcerated um
the other we have less of a no-show
issue because most of the time um
they're there and readily willing to
talk to us get them out of out of their
room for a little while um so we have
less of a no-show rate we still do get
some refusals um especially those who um
maybe seriously mental eal so sometimes
they don't show up but um the high
no-show
rate I think the medical records are the
other thing for the um for the
incarcerated those apply to
both follow up please follow up sure uh
what percentage of the people requiring
uh mental evaluation are non- incar
incarcerated I calculated this number
not that long ago for someone
um I believe if I'm Rec calling
correctly um that my estimate over the
last 2 years was about 30% incarcerated
and 70% non-incarcerated is that right
okay yep go ahead
uh so is is this a issue with uh being
able to go forward with the uh the trial
yes not getting the uh evaluation yes
everything is placed on hold until the
court has the evaluation and the judge
makes the determination whether or not
someone is legally competent or if
they're not competent then they move
into a restoration
period thank you other questions so I I
guess I have oh I'm sorry representative
Smith go ahead could you just explain
what you mean by the road
restoration yes so the three questions
that we answer at the office of forensic
examiners uh when we write a report um
under the current statute statute is the
first whether or not uh the individual
or expert opinion and whether or not
they have a mental disease or disorder
whether or not they have um
a um factual and rational understanding
of the legal proceedings and whether or
not they have the ability to assist
their attorney in their
defense if those are lacking then we
will make an opinion
regarding how those deficits that they
may have impact their legal skills and
which skills so that the court can
decide whether or not they're competent
or incompetent under the current statute
if our opinion is that the individual is
not competent at this time um then the
defendant is to be excuse me the
defendant shall be ordered to
Restoration unless there is clear and
convincing evidence that they that it is
unlikely or is not likely that they will
be restored to competency in the next
year so the office forensic examiner
then offers an opinion on whether or not
there is appropriate treatment that is
likely to restore the individual in the
next year and if that treatment uh and
what that treatment is as far as
treatment recommendations to take place
in that restoration period at the end of
the restoration period then they will be
referred back to the office of the fren
examiners for a restoration evaluation
at which time we will once again conduct
a competency evaluation and offer an
opinion as to whether or not they are
competent and been restored or not
competent and not restored if I could
just follow up where does that
restoration take
place restoration takes place in the
community um in the majority of cases
some restoration will take place if the
individual if the court um deems that
the
individual needs to remain romantic in
the county jail um or at um the spew or
at New Hampshire hospital thank
you well I I guess I I have um a couple
of questions the first question I have
is is this um
this is this proposal I I understand
that it's it's sort of prompted by the
department of corrections but has the
Attorney General reviewed is the
Attorney General on board with this so
to
speak um I can't speak for their office
but we did write it um with a member of
the Attorney General's staff so they
were involved in the process all right
sure so then a couple just a couple of
questions one um I see on um on the
first page there's reference to uh the
evaluations be being conducted by
electronic means and I I have to say I'm
I'm just a little I'm I'm just a little
surprised that is that something that's
being done now that you're doing
evaluations by electronic means yes um
um the um the pivot for that um really
in our office changed with um covid um
however it is a practice that has
continued in some
cases um and um it is a process that
will be continuing um probably more so
in the near future we'll be doing more
remote evaluations there is research in
the field um that remote evaluations um
can be and are equal to the opinions and
competency evaluations of those
conducted in person um so we plan to
continue and likely increase the amount
of remote evaluations that will be
occurring in the future and I'm curious
what what has been the reaction of the
defense bar to that are they okay with
that or you get a lot of objections that
you know we no we want it in person um
no uh I don't get I wouldn't say we get
a lot of objections um we look at I
review evaluations before I no not
evaluations I review records if we have
them and I review the discovery um and I
evaluate whether or not the case would
be clinically appropriate I try to
screen out those cases that are not
clinically appropriate um those may need
more extensive testing or those that may
have um some specific paranoia with
technology might be an ex the first
example that comes to mind um and those
typically are I don't try I don't even
try video conference we just schedule
for in person
um in those cases where we have councel
reach out and say I don't think my
client would do well by video um then I
respect that opinion as they know their
client best at that point they've had
the most interaction and we will
schedule an iners um although there may
be
some changes um in the future with
regard to how often we do that
at this point in time we've been able to
offer in-person
evaluations um when needed okay then my
final question is um am I understanding
correctly that when with regard to the
records issue I would
assume that
before a lawyer for a CL for a defendant
would agree to records being disclosed
that the lawyer would have looked at the
records himself or herself to make sure
that there's I mean I presume that that
the lawyer would not say sure just I'm
going to allow a release of all these
records with not knowing what's in them
yes typically um the records come from
through the defense Council so even in
those cases when there's a court order
for us to get the records directly it
also usually has them sent directly to
the defense Council the the Judges
usually put both of those in those court
orders okay and so then the next
question I have is is this if the I I
have no problem at all with the idea
that if defense you know that defense
Council should make the decision of of
what records should be going to
um the forensic examiner um in the first
instance I only um the the only question
I have is if
the this seems to say that that some
records could be
provided to the to you to conduct the
evaluation which uh which would then not
be disclosed to the state and I guess
I'm that does trouble me a little bit in
other words if you have if you have
information that you're basing a
decision on that is not disclosed to the
state why that that is troubling to me
because the defense knows about it
obviously yes so um there are two issues
I I so with a defense attorney um their
role their job and their purpose is to
defend their
client if we presume that they have
reviewed the records and released to us
the records that they believe to be
relevant or um would
uh present their client in a light that
helps them which is their job is to is
to help their client and work for their
client then we may miss important
information um
that may not serve their purposes of
defending their client to the best of
their ability because they have ethical
and obligation to their client so I am
um leery to say that I want all records
approved by defense counsel before they
send them to me now there are times
where I get records that have been
redacted and I let the court know that
those records were redacted because it
limits my opinion I don't know what they
redacted or why it was reacted did they
redact some information that maybe
speaks to dangerousness which is an
issue that I have to address if they are
found not competent and not restorable
under State V Lavoy so I am somewhat
leery to say that I want all records to
be approved by defense although I do
agree that if if those records were sent
directly to us that the defense
Council should have the ability to ask
the court for those records to be
provided to them as well if it was not
already because they should have access
to the same information regarding their
client um as from an forensic examiner
standpoint I don't have a problem with
them having the confidential information
about their client whether or not
prosecution gets access to that that is
a question for the court that is not
something that we would be releasing we
do not release any records any reports
anything without a direct order from the
court okay so you and I'm sorry I I know
I I understand what you're saying I mean
I do agree with you that the defense
Council shouldn't be able to you know if
there's
some very unfavorable information in the
medical records about violence or
something like that the the defense
Council shouldn't be able to hide that
from you in making a a determination but
I guess what I was sort of saying is
um if whatever information you receive
whatever information you base a decision
on it's hard for me to understand why
that information shouldn't be available
then to both
sides oh that's sort of above my pay
grade
um um that uh I mean that is a that's a
Judicial that's a that is a question
that goes to the judge um of whether or
not that information should be provided
to to both parties that is as a forensic
examiner I am an independent evaluator
tasked with providing information to the
court the legal questions beside the
lawyers of who should have what
information what is admissible what is
here say those are questions that we
then as examiners defer to the
court um I will add okay that particular
language um we there is an objection
with the original way that this bill was
written by the defense Lawyers
Association um we sat down me being the
Department of Corrections with um
Senator Chanley and the ACLU and the New
Hampshire defense attorneys to kind of
come up language that they would agree
to yeah the only thing I mean the thing
I guess the thing that concerns me is
the maybe the last sentence in paragraph
e about um the court
consider the C the person's privacy
interest in the content of the
records
um and I I mean I I guess my concern is
if you've how what however strong the
person's privacy interest in the records
may be that might be a reason for those
records not to be given to you but if
they are given to you then it you know
it and then presumably that goes into
your evaluation and if that's you know
if that's true it's hard for me to
understand why those records then should
not be available to both
sides I understand what you're saying I
think that those aren't records that we
would provide without a court order now
so that it's not changing sure I don't
know I understand I mean I can
understand you would want a court order
but I'm just sort of saying that you
know to the extent that this would say
to the court
well um the Privacy interest
um I mean it would seem to me that to
the extent there's a privacy interest
that the court should be considering
that initially as to whether or not you
you get the records at all but once you
do get the
records it you know I can see some
unfairness in in those records being
available only to one side I will say
that that is um an argument that I have
seen come across um in motions um from
the prosecution teams um and that um
that is current being discussed in
courts across the state okay all right
well anyway I mean that's that that's a
we can sort of TW tweak the language a
little bit I think probably all right
any other questions yes representa
Lorenzo who pays for all of
this we do do you mean this um
evaluations does it the evaluations um
so the office of forensic examiner is um
funded through the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections at this time
yes and we're primarily a general funded
organization so followup please so this
doesn't um hit the um the client's
health insurance or anything we're not b
no okay thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you all right um yes anyone
else um here that wishes to testify on
uh Senate Bill
314 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 314 and we've got
about five minutes before we open the
hearing on the next bill
than I can have some
relatively
what was that initially I had objection
but what she said and I think she was
very sincere and genuine she body she
doesn't share any of this stuff yeah it
only goes into her report and once her
report is done that's it and
and she seemed to be very credible oh
yeah oh I agree I agree I yeah I mean
you know I I guess I think I
probably
e
so it's um it's now uh past 10:45 five
and I'm going to um open uh the hearing
on uh Senate Bill three
27 um the prime sponsor is uh Senator uh
delandro don't see him here is there
anybody here to uh well he he's on his
way but oh he is on his way oh oh all
right in the hallway I mean oh great
that's great great great great great
wait or should I no I just read into
Senator aland okay oh great thank
you yeah
yeah I mean I can formerly introduce it
if you wanted me to I can just wait a
minute till he's there he
is Senator Senator welcome welcome great
to be here great to have you
here thank you uh thank you Mr chairman
for the record I'm Senator lud elisandro
I present District 20 that's Manchester
WS 2 3 and 4 10 uh 11 and 12 I come
before you as the prime sponsor of
Senate Bill
314 relative
to uh oh excuse me providing penal
excuse me 327 providing penal assault or
harassment on Sports officials and uh
obviously
uh having been involved in athletics all
of my life as a player a coach and as a
teacher I've seen what's happening in in
the sports world and it's very
disturbing the the way uh officials are
treated the language that's used in in
the stands by by individuals and really
the the behavior that that takes place
which totally takes away from the game
itself these these games were were were
organized for the enjoyment of the
players so that they could play for the
enjoyment of the fans so that they could
enjoy uh the the spec from a spectator's
standpoint watching the the game as it
it it proceeds and what's happened is
chaos has enter the
situation and uh it it's very disturbing
to me as I said as a player and and as a
coach a to to to see what's going on to
see the to see and hear the language
that's that's being used by fans and and
some of these fans it's it's it's very
very disturbing and my grandchildren uh
have been players and I've gone to their
games and uh you can see this happening
and it's it's it's just uh it's it's a
very bad
thing it's an example of what's
happening to the society I think the
society is be becoming more corrupted
chaotic and that disturbs me so what's
the way to deal with it well the way to
deal with it in my opinion is to create
a piece of legislation that protects the
official think of this young kid who
want who's uh who's learning to be an
official who who's working a game and
who's who's just totally harassed by
some individual from the STS uh or some
individual and and this loses their
interest in being an official you know
how difficult it is to find an official
today someone to officiate a game so
uh brought this piece of legislation
forward
and uh talks about the event the
participant the event the official and
the person who commits the first-degree
assault there was a penalty associated
with this and I've been asked this
numerous times who's going to oversee
all of this well for every athletic
event there there's an administrative
person who usually puts the event
together it's someone from someone from
the school and it's certainly at the
postsecondary level at somebody from
from the college so so indeed there is
there is uh a way to to mootor to this
so with that Mr shamman I thank you so
much for allowing me to come and testify
I'll try to address any questions that
you you you may have and got a call
yesterday from ESPN about this so it's
gravitating across the country this is
not just in New Hampshire the kind of
behavior that we're seeing and I'll give
you two illustrations that were very
disturbing to me the young woman who
plays for the University of Iowa the the
scoring leader of of the world
U after she made a basket the uh you
know the the
crowd ran onto the floor and knocked her
over she could have had a permanent
injury just because of this crazy
behavior then I watched the Duke game
when Duke was playing uh I think they
might have been playing Wake Forest the
same things happened and a Duke player
went went down now there's no there's no
need for that I understand enthusiasm
and so forth and so on but these are
graphic illustrations of what's
happening the chaos that's entering uh
our athletic C tests uh so I think there
something has to be has to be done about
it so with that I'll try to address any
queries that you may have and thank you
so much for your attention appreciate it
thank you judge no thank you and I uh
are there questions I have to say senat
I I applaud you if I think this you're
ABS I agree with everything you've said
and uh you're going to get you're going
to get my vote that's for sure but
questions uh for for members of the
committee just just mine too um I mean
guess this is a bill focused on this one
issue but there's a slightly larger
issue too where um people well I guess
everybody present in the event is is a
participant under this definition where
people who
are uh Spectators assault uh players or
coaches too because they disagree what
they're doing so would um just why did
you focus the B on this one issue which
is which is fine but I guess I don't
know whether want to speak to that
larger issue at all sure well thank you
for the question I I I think Behavior
per se is really out out of bounds I I
think people people don't understand
that when they buy a ticket to the venue
they bought a ticket to watch a contest
they're not participants
right they can cheer from the sidelines
but but but they they're not calling the
place and and and they're
not going after a person who might make
a mistake or something of that nature
but they're participant that's what this
listen this is not the Roman
Coliseum this the these supposedly are
games you know and I participated in
these games as as a youngster as a
college player I played a little
professionally but this whole thing is
has gotten gotten way just way out of
hand and I I I noticed that in in arenas
now they when when there's a time out
they they have people who line up along
along the sidelines well that's from the
professional standpoint from the
congression when you get down to the to
the to the uh you know postsecondary
level uh there are efforts to control
the crows it it's a it's it's at now
it's at the lowest level I mean it's
high school and Junior High
School it it's it's amazing to me and I
I I went to many athletic many athletic
contexts and I still go to them and uh
as I said I see the behavior the
language kills me I I mean I can't
believe I can't believe some of the
language that's thrown around
but I think it's a societal question we
got to get a hold of uh representative
Smith and then representative k
um thank you Senator I think everybody
agrees with you about the problem I if I
could would like to uh find a way to add
an amendment about the language in the
uh used in the New Hampshire House of
Representatives but I'm not going to ask
that that you agree to that kind of an
amendment um I'm glad you're laughing I
don't laugh when I hear um my question
is do you really believe
that providing
penalties for that behavior will in fact
make a difference when you so eloquently
have
explained the change in the culture that
we are now suffering
through thank you thank you for those
comments excellent C sure do do I think
it it'll help because every time you
present a a a penalty there is some
reaction to it but will the masses react
to it in a positive fashion I I I
honestly don't know I I think we we we
need to we need to change Behavior
pths people now perceive that these
things are okay they aren't they aren't
okay and I I give you the perfect
example of it's not okay the incident
that took place at Gillette Stadium
where two people went at each other uh
over
over over something that had no meaning
at all and and the guy ends up
dying well what the hell are we talking
about we we supposedly go to these
contests a because we enjoy watching the
activity and we enjoy being with our
friends and and family take take my take
your kids or your grandchildren to a
games so they'll they'll enjoy it and
then have something like like this
happen that I mean it's it's terrible
we're get we're just getting way out of
hand in in again in my opinion and and
and and as the representative Smith
points out it's it's behavior in this
legislature I've been here a long time I
remember when this was a pretty good
place when people really respected one
another and respected one another's
views uh and and accept him uh that's
that's maybe moving in in the the
opposite direction but this deals with
one aspect one aspect of is it going to
change society no but is it an attempt
to make it better yes and that's what
we're here for to try to make things
better representative
katat thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question Senator de de
Sandro and for putting in the bill I
just have one question so the example
that you had mentioned relative to the
sports players being knocked over from
people from the stands coming in I
noticed that this bill is limited only
to the harassment of sports officials
and I was wondering if you would be open
potentially to amending to also include
just the assault in in if you would be
supportive of amending to
include the assault of I guess players
as well since that also seems to be or
even other fans in the stand I mean it
just seems like you know none of this
Behavior should be allowed especially
when it's rising to the level of of
assault sure thank you thank you for the
cage sure sure I think you're you're
exactly correct the thing is how far can
we go I I think we we got a tail of
something that that we can actually deal
with and uh you're absolutely right in
terms
of anything that makes a piece of
legislation better uh and that makes it
work I I I think you know that's why am
that's why we amend bills and that's why
we have these meetings that's why we we
have conversation about the bill so that
we get input from others as how do how
can we make the bill better and make it
more effective and I think I appreciate
your comments I think they're very
worthwhile representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm wondering
about the distinction
between people watch
and how do
you
do of an
official being phal and and I'm
wondering about wisdom of including
verbal
Behavior well thank you for the comments
thank you for the question um verbal
Behavior can be pretty assaulting you
know uh and I'm sure you've witnessed
some of it
as as I have uh I'm going to kill you I
mean who wait a minute you know and then
you find out that the person's got a gun
and they shoot you that's happened you
know and and again let me just give you
the example that's most disturbing to me
the Kansas City Chiefs won the Super
Bowl they have a huge rally about
800,000 people gathered in Kansas City
to celebrate it some did with pulls out
a gun and starts shooting
people
U what think think of that now now I I
look at the news every evening and try
to read the paper in the morning and and
I look at the number of activities like
this that are taking place around the
country that these aren't a athletically
oriented but that one that I've cited is
a particular athletic I I think we're
getting that we're getting a little bit
out of control and
meaning uh meaningful uh meaningful
accusations of meaningful languag is uh
it could be very disturbing it could be
very disturbing we we can't control
everything so let's cut out a piece that
we think we could work on it and try to
make it
better representative trip did you have
a question uh representative kab jumped
it okay representative orgon um this is
slightly larger question but um I know
since you been involved with un Sports
even after your outstanding performance
on the field and um and of course one of
the things that a lot of the you know
the children's Sports the parents are
often convinced that their kids are on
their way to a college college
scholarship or even a pro career but is
it probably fair to say that no one's uh
no one's career potential future career
in college Pro Sports ever depends on
just one call that some amateur official
makes during a youth game and also just
on on a uh thank you for the
question yeah sure you could never
attribute success or failure to that
wood to that wood call we we T we you
know we tend to comp compartmentalize
things today as they affect us
directly and and that that's just not
the way that's not the way that not the
way to do it as it relates to a to to a
call yeah thanks and also of course the
activity is worthwhile I guess even in
and of itself even if you don't make it
to the pros like I actually got a nice
postcard encouraging me to renew my
season ticket subscription from a Casey
DeAndre who was an outstanding college
player and actually guess was signed to
a pro contract but didn't make the cut
but he still you know he still moved on
to a good career as a coach after
playing so like there's more to it than
just Mak a college scholarship or
playing the pros too of course yeah well
we're we're happy when the athletes
could move all to a better station in
life and become good citizens that's
kind what it's all about yes
representative
Tri representative Horan brought up a a
excellent point uh I've I have
grandchildren if you can believe that
and uh they're Sports people and uh i'
go in the Su of their games and uh the
uh it's interesting the
uh they relaxation of the
uh rules in some of the games you know I
think that's probably you know something
that uh I know I've gone like this to
the uh officials and uh I'm sure that's
probably offensive in some manner would
would this bill apply to
that well that's that thank you for the
C that's pretty far-reaching
but it it it applies as to uh the event
the official the person who's who's
officiating it and and talks about the
rules who enforces the rules irees
referees timers scorers regardless of
whether the person's paid or doesn't get
but so it's it's it's helpful in that
respect we're trying to cover as many
bases as we can to handle a situation
that has become
pervasive and uh try to put the capital
and uh and do something uh and do
something about
it this is a this is one this is one
step and we're trying to do the best we
can with this one
step Mr chair yes representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question Senator do you
think that some of the music that's
played during some of these events is
pumping people
up that's that's a good question
sure that's what it's I mean the fans
yes get a hype site sure it and in some
ways you know that's that's a good thing
if it just promotes cheering and
supporting the team you know that that's
all part of that's all part of the game
really it's an
event and as a friend of mine said uh
these are social events and we've we've
what we've done is we've taken the event
and we've we've given it an expans of
quality uh where it where it used to be
a game now now it's
uh it's a little bit more than that
thank you thank you representative
Smith Senator before I'm called out of
order for this
question um I would ask you do you think
this complete lack of respect for
institutions
could be best addressed if respect for
institutions started at the
top yeah it's a great question of course
me look at
uh the great the great reference is
listen everything everything starts at
the top it flows
down and when it when that happens in in
a positive manner you you get you get a
good result
but uh
sure
uh and uh it's kind of the way it should
be so I Senator one of the things I
particularly like about this bill is I
think I think it you you
wisely did not you made the penalties
for the for the offenses the same as the
penalties for whatever the underlying
crime and I thought that was good and
but I particularly like
this the Roman numeral 3 which which
allows the court to
impose uh uh exclusion from uh
attending uh sports events I mean I
think that's you know that may be that
may be the thing that is the most
telling penalty and I think I think it's
a very you know an excellent an
excellent idea uh we thank you thank you
we we'll we'll thank the drafters for
that
uh sure and I think that's a that's a
big that's a very important part of the
deal uh excluding those people right for
sure right other questions for s yes
representative Kenny I thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um so I just have a question
since we've heard about uh possible
amendments and other issues that could
be tackled you know involving players
and fans and whatnot is it would it be
your preference or do you suggest that
we tack this one issue in this piece of
legislation and those are ideas for the
future or would you like to see this
amended to tackle those other issues
thank you well thank you thank you for
the comments I I think um what I want to
see is is the legislation passed uh so
that we get something uh something in
place uh I I think it's really your
decision as to whether you exp the scope
of of of the legislation or not that's
why we have these hearings and and
indeed um
that's that's the will of that's the
will of the
committee I I think a person comes here
and presents their views on a piece of
legislation based on what they have
brought forth in the document that I
brought I have brought forth represents
what what I perceive and the and the
drafters of this perceive as the
addressing the question that that I
brought forth when I asked them to draft
this legislation but but listen there's
no pride of authorship in this world
anymore you know everything is uh uh I
think
everything everything is always subject
to to uh enhancement let's put it that
way other questions for Senator
delandra seeing none thank you very much
Senator thank you for uh for being here
and for this bill I think it's a very
important Bill thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you thank the committee
for your
Indulgence so uh next I'm going to call
on uh Attorney Stuart dlos from Durham
who I would note is not only an
excellent attorney but I also an
excellent basketball referee at least
and maybe others I've he's refereed some
of my granddaughter's games and done an
excellent job I would
say oh of course sure that's no that's
fine M let me Mr Flynn why don't you
come up first then please just for the
record attorney to office is also an
outstanding soccer official
too yeah make sure that's it thank you
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Kevin Flynn I'm from hopkington
and I'm representing the uh New
Hampshire Baseball umpires Association
that's the association that does uh
officiating for high school games but
all the umpires including myself we do
all levels Cal Ripken Babe Ruth uh adult
wck leagues we have all that um doing
games for a lot of the districts you
represent here Windom gown I think my
home openers Hollis game and Manchester
of course and I'd like to remind the
chair that in his uh previous uh uh
career that when he was in charge of the
softball team at the superior report in
Manchester that he contacted me when I
was uh running the softball team at the
radio station and asked for a game and I
to preserve this legislation I will not
remind him what the score was uh but we
had a wonderful time thank you we had
just you the members of the comme will
know especially the lawyers will
understand our team name was the
harmless erors that's what we called
ourselves M Mr uh chair and how was the
behavior at the
game the behavior at the game was
Behavior at the game was fine after the
game we might have you know repaired to
a uh
uh an
establishment right right uh so I want
to thank Senator delis Sandro who worked
with us on on the legislation and for
your uh your comments uh uh Mr chair I
also spoke with that reporter from ESPN
yesterday and there are 22 other states
that have legislation addressing
protection of of uh Sports officials
this legislative session 13 other states
are looking at legislation of different
types and her question was why now and
uh I think it's it's a bill it's time
has come it's an issue that has been
long festering in our Sports culture
kill the UMP you know uh coming out
bumping the chest kicking dirt uh on the
Umpire as you said there's just a
General loss of Civility as I'm sure
you've seen in your own emails sent to
you and uh but more I think it's it's
coming to aead because now people have
uh cameras with them and we've seen
plenty of online videos that have
shocked us um with uh officials getting
punched getting you know knocked down uh
followed to their car and
harassed and uh you know this the stats
are here in New Hampshire that
11% of sports officials report having
been assaulted uh during a game or after
a game and that 40% have been made to
feel unsafe and I think it's that people
behave on a field or in an auditorium or
uh the grid iron or in the stands in a
way they never would at work or in a
restaurant and say things to people they
would never say to a waiter or a
coworker or a person on the street
because they feel like it's part of the
game and that for some reason within the
confines of the ball field or the
gymnasium the rules that sort of guide
us decorum and of criminality somehow
don't apply and uh that's caused a
shortage of officials uh doing these
games across all sports at at the Senate
hearing we had representatives from
football basketball volleyball lacrosse
the soccer um and they have all said
that this has become a problem not just
the high school level but all levels
that the the officials are leaving in
drobes primarily a lot of them are aging
out and we're not getting young ones
coming in but primarily for harassment
and other this kind of this kind of
issue um I'd say just based on sort of
the the initial questions from the
committee I don't think this bill is as
far-reaching as maybe the questions seem
to apply I think this bill is very
modest and elegant certainly compared to
what other states have other states have
something or they're proposing something
to can assault on a police officer
being assault on on an official really
all this bill does and he pointed out in
Roman 3 is that uh all this really it
this doesn't change the definition of
any assault if you look at at Roman 2
basically the offender has to commit the
crime it's already on the book first
degree assault simple assault criminal
threatening there isn't you know we're
not criminalizing arguing they're not
trying to codify good sportsmanship so
something represent like just kind of
going like that you know we're not going
to say please bring an officer in but I
think what this does is that for the
person who does commit one of these
crimes against an official on the field
this adds an additional penalty that
what act as a deterrent if you could say
that in addition to you know uh being uh
charged with a felony or whatever that
you can't watch your kid for a year or
that you can never come back because
you've done this the second time that's
very powerful
I think and it it sends a message and
you know why would not this bill uh
address these kinds of behaviors uh
directed towards fans or players I I
would just say that house is not on fire
and this house is on fire and you know
maybe uh an additional bill down the
road could address that it's the
prerogative of the of the committee
obviously to amend it and make it
stronger right now we think this is you
know again this is very elegant bill
that addresses hopefully addresses the
problem um so I think lastly it it
hopefully accomplishes two things one it
sends a message to all coaches players
parents and quite frankly to police and
prosecutors and judges who might be
dealing uh with a case like this that
this is not part of the game that
assault is assault and criminal
threatening is threatening and
harassment is harassment and these are
laws that we already have but for some
reason in this context people don't seem
to understand it's not part of the game
and it will keep us safe and if the game
is not safe for officials it's not safe
for the children who play it so uh and
I've submitted written testimony and so
to not belabor it I'm happy to answer
any questions see about the legislation
or about what is happening out there
that I I could answer for you questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you Mr
dlos it was the only game we won that
[Laughter]
year that's G to be a tough act to
follow oh I'm sorry my name is for the
record Stuart dlas I'm an attorney I
practice in Durham New Hampshire I'm now
affiliated with the coolage law firm
which is located in summersworth my
partner and I merged with him on August
1st of last year on November 30 1981
when I was a sophomore at the University
of Vermont I completed the Apprentice
program took the written test and passed
it and became a certified basketball
official the following March of
1981 when I passed the so-called floor
test that's when someone observes you to
make sure you know where to stand and
how to raise your hand and do stuff like
that it wasn't until six years later on
February 1
1977 that I was sworn into practice
before the New Hampshire Supreme Court
when George Papa gianis the clerk
introduced James yakovac who was there
for an oral argument who introduced
Stuart doop so I like to say it was Papa
gianis to Yakov vakas to toas sort of
like Tinker St to chance if you follow
baseball but not quite as famous so I've
been a basketball referee longer than
I've been a lawyer I just completed my
53rd year uh there are very few of us
who do 50 years as an official uh I'm
proud of the fact that I've actually
officiated at the varsity I contined to
officiate at the varsity level in my
53rd year a lot of people just um go
down to the middle school games I do
some of those as well and I took up
soccer officiating in
1997 when my daughter was young and I
thought it would be nice to get out in
the afternoons and enjoy some of the
weather in New
Hampshire I also have a background I
have a little packet that I'd like to
submit later on that has just some
biographical information I've had an
interest in sports law since I was in
law school after I got out of law school
starting in 1978 I began to co-author
articles for referee magazine which was
a nationwide publication for sports
officials uh it's the magazine now and I
also participated in a couple of
conferences put on by the National
Association of sports officials
primarily because my law school friend
was a driving force uh behind that and I
also have a little blur out of a case
from North Carolina where the judges
talk about uh why people go to sporting
events I'll let you read that yourself
and as Kevin mentioned the National
Association National Association of
sports officials publishes uh
information through referee magazine
primarily and I have a packet that I
printed out for you which shows the
different states that have legislation
the different states that are
considering it a list of the type of uh
legislation that's been passed and print
out of the laws if you're interested uh
I think uh Kevin made the most important
point about what's going on here uh with
this legislation this legislation is
targeted to a
specific issue and that issue is if a
person commits a crime we're not talking
about bad behavior we're talking about a
crime and that victim is a sports
official is there anything on the books
now that would enable a judge to Clearly
say to that person in addition to the
sentence I'm going to impose
I'm going to ban you from going to a
sporting
event there isn't anything like that in
the criminal
code I think a judge probably could do
that but I think it's unclear but this
bill would make it clear that the court
has that Authority it's just another
tool in the sentencing toolbox that a
judge can use but I just wanted to
Circle back for those of you who have
never officiated you really need to
understand that the reason that these
arguments are so vicious at these
sporting events is because they're so
little at
stake the adults for some reason are
trying to relive their youth or they're
enamored with a prospect that their kid
who's the 12th person sitting on the
bench is going to be a division one
athlete and they won't have to pay
tuition uh or something else is going on
in their life but it's become
increasingly distressing to see what
people are doing in the arenas what
people are saying in the Arenas and
sometimes and this happened to me at the
end of a soccer game I did U more much
in the school because the school was
very supportive but I was walking across
the field with my partner who was a
championship level official so we we
were doing a decent job and he was doing
a great job and somebody started to
approach us probably a parent from one
of the uh from the losing team uh
berating us for not giving a red card to
somebody and the athletic directors just
stood and said just go back the trouble
with now is in society is you don't know
if someone's going to come up and
actually hit you or pull a gun or do
something like that that I think is what
we're facing as officials that's what is
discouraging people from becoming
involved in this and I know that
firsthand because and I know the date
because I used to keep a chart when I
first started to officiate or where I
officiated when I was officiating who I
was officiating with and how much I got
paid because they needed it for tax
purposes on March 2 1981 in DOA New
Hampshire at the old Butterfield gym
which is now the Children's Museum when
I was doing a playoff game in the men's
league I got paid $15 and I did two
games and I have a note in the right-and
column that's what I usually put down if
I called it technical foul or something
I was assaulted by a player after the
game and as I was telling the senate
committee what happened was it I walked
out and this fellow who looked like a
weightlifter who's really strong well
built I'm just the opposite of I what I
look like and he must have been
irritated I must have called a technical
voul probably didn't deserve it in his
mind and like I said I mean they
probably lost the game so I mean who
else do you take your frustration on out
on but the officials so he saw me walk
out of the gym in the corridor and he
grabbed me I think it was with his left
hand and he put it under my chin and put
me up against the wall in front of his
friends I thought he was going to hit me
um dropped his let me go down to the
floor and then I walked away uh
unfortunately for him because I knew the
prosecutor and do at the time I dictated
about an eight-page statement to the
secretary I was working for trino at
that time I took it down to the police
department and I asked my friend who was
Prosecuting to file a criminal charge
which they did and about two months
later I got a phone call from another
friend he said uh I said oh what's going
on he said IET this guy who came into my
office he was charged with assaulting
you got arrested
he said you know what do you want to do
I said I think the Chief Justice can
appreciate this I said did you get paid
he goes oh yeah I get the money up front
I said well I really don't care I really
don't care I wanted to teach him a
lesson so this stuff happens I don't I
don't think there are um that many
physical assaults yet I don't think
there that many cars that are being
keyed or uh windshields broken uh I'm
not not sure that uh people are getting
phone calls at home uh all of which
we're afraid might happen down the road
I think I think the problem is that
people feel that they can do this and
there isn't any
ramification this bill is not going to
change the way people act inside of a
basketball arena or at a soccer field
you cannot legislate good behavior you
can't make a criticism free zone and
sporting
event what we want as officials I think
is that when people cross the line
because I have tools as an official if
someone has giv me a hard time and I
think they're being
disruptive I can say something nicely to
them I can ask the athletic director to
go over and just say can you tell that
guy to shut up or if it's really bad I
can just ask the athletic director stop
the game and that guy's got to leave we
can do all of those things so we can
deal with it it creates a problem
sometimes because if you have somebody
out of control when you escalated it by
removing them you don't know what's
going to happen but we have tools that
can do that and we're not asking anybody
to worry about how we do that because
people have a right to go to an event
and be a jerk if they want to they can
be a jerk to the officials we see them
talking in a derogatory fashion to other
12-year-old kids we see them arguing
amongst each other in the
stands it's unbelievable I there was a
summer league game when I heard one
parent say well if he does do that hit
him back with the elbow that's a great
message for a kid in junior high school
or playing on the junor varsity so we're
worried about the criminal offenses and
when the matter was before the uh Senate
there was a suggestion which I think is
good there was a suggestion to add to
paragraph two which includes simple
assault Reckless conduct criminal
threatening
harassment to add stalking and criminal
mischief uh to the bill which I think
would be a good
idea and what what we'd like to see as
Sports officials is if someone does
something to us and it has to be a
crime and we have to be the named victim
we like this additional penalty that the
Chief Justice had mentioned and that
Kevin had mentioned that additional
penalty that the judge can say and by
the way you can't go to a game that your
kid is playing in for a
year now if people don't know about this
bill in it passes the problem is how are
they going to be dis discouraged from
acting uh in a criminal fashion and what
I hope is that if the bill passes that
the uh officiating organizations and I
would delegate this to Kevin because he
does a good job at this that the
supervisors contact the schools through
the athletic directors maybe through the
school boards and try to get them on
board where they put something up in the
school where they talk to the coaches
and the players before the season starts
they have parent meetings and just tell
them this is what's going to happen if
we have a problem you're not going to be
here watching your kid so you've got to
talk to your friends and try to Tamper
it down is it going to make a big
difference I'm not really sure I hope it
does it'll make some difference but
it'll give us you know some feeling of
satisfaction and maybe that's the wrong
word but if something happens that we
don't have to go to a game and see that
person there
um the
um comment I had about the bill before
the Senate which I would make here as
well is that excuse
me um I think in paragraph
two
um it seems to suggest that this this is
a new statute so this is a new crime
and I think it would be better to use
the word misdemeanor instead of offense
in paragraph two so that it is brought
as a criminal offense and I say that
because when we talk in paragraph three
about a person being fined for contempt
of court I think it would be cleaner if
a judge could just say to somebody I'm
going to give you a suspended jail
sentence or a suspended fine and it's on
two conditions one is good behavior and
the other is is you can't go to the game
and then if the person sneaks into the
next game they might face the imposition
the 30-day sentence or the imposition of
the fine I just think that would be
cleaner it's not a big deal but it's
something I mentioned before the
Senate uh so I hope you would seriously
consider passing this I think you'd be
surprised how many people I've been
around a long time so people see me in
town and see me at sporting events and
I've had people say to me I saw you on
television uh talking about that bill
that's a great idea
so the number you know the percentage of
people that we're talking about who
caused problems for us is relatively
small but it's still significant and
like Kevin said um our numbers are down
really down in Soco last year there were
days when our
assigner had junior varsity and freshman
games officiated by only one official
and on one day he had about 20 games
like
that 20 games with only one official
because we don't have enough people and
other people were doubling up and in
basketball some of my friends do three
games they'll go to a a school and do a
freshman game a junior varsity and a
varsity or they'll go to one school do a
freshman game and then go to another
school and do the varsity game so it's
it's not good and most of the people are
getting aged out or they should be aged
out when they're officiating but we're
all hanging on uh because we like it
and because the kids wouldn't be able to
play so we don't want the parents
running it for
them uh representative Smith question
thank you very much
um
uh I I don't know whether I'm the bull
in the china shop or another one of
those the fly what's the other
expression what whatever it is what I'm
going to say is not going to be welcome
I
know that sports are an important part
of our
society I know that our children learn
an incredible amount by being able to
play on teams they learn about working
with others they learn physical skills
they learn about winning and
losing um and one hopes they learn good
behavior
um what makes me
unhappy
today
is why are we looking at
Sports and not looking at any other
Gathering of people where the
behavior um is not behavior that you or
I would have ever
seen a number of years ago um whether
it's in a a theater a concert or a
political Gathering where things are
said
um there's physical assault there's
verbal assault that is the world that
we're living in right now and it's
wrong so as important as I think sports
are in in our
children's development and we're talking
here you know about young people
I I'm just really uncomfortable that
we're spending a lot of time here
talking about this which is the tiniest
component of the problems that we are
facing now in the world we're living in
can you tell me where I'm wrong I don't
think you're wrong but I I think the
issue for us you know I don't speak for
all officials but I think I speak for
most of them on this point
is if there's no authority to ban
someone okay and then somebody comes up
and pushes me and then they get
prosecuted and they get a suspended as
jail sentence and they can come back to
the arena again that's problematic for
us so we think that that we're unique in
that
regard and that's why this bill is
important for
us you might be right that other bills
could designate um other people as
victims or other groups as victims and
that would be fine but we think for us
the time has come to have that little
tool in the toolbox that people know
about where they they're not coming back
they if they don't behave
properly thank you that shows why you're
a good Advocate representative
trip uh I think you brought up a an
excellent comment on uh section three
but uh uh you know but uh I just have a
question on attendance Pro prohibition
uh do you have any suggestions on uh how
this would be
enforced uh especially you
know if you're banned
from uh say a home game how would uh the
officials at the away game know that the
person is banned or or does that
actually
apply I think I think word would get
around it's it's just like anything else
in our business you client I used to be
a public defenders get restrictions on
certain things that that people couldn't
do um and usually people know about them
so I so I would guess that if we knew
that that a particular person couldn't
go to a sporting event we would probably
disseminate that information through the
athletic
directors representative oh I'm sorry
you want to follow up follow up please
so so you don't propose that we have a a
a list that is uh propagated by
uh people that are convicted of banned
from uh
uh athletic events distributed to uh all
the schools so that they would be a
mechanism for enforcement you mean like
a registry yes um personally I would
rather maybe see the nhiaa get involved
where we could report that somehow to
the NHA
and they send out an email to their
member of
schools okay thank you my guess would my
guess would be if you're a parent and
you're banned from a school and you've
been in front of a judge and you have a
suspended sentence you're probably not
going to go to another game unless
you're a complete idiot and if you're a
complete idiot you're probably going to
get caught based upon my experience in
dealing with people
so representative
kab
sorry I guess I guess yeah you had
another followup go ahead uh Sor so I
guess uh is there additional penalties
for repeat violations of uh attending
games when you're banned from games on
on this proposal it's up to a year for
the first offense and up to life a
lifetime ban
thereafter up to a lifetime ban all
right thank you representative
kab thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question attorney I wanted
to ask relative to line
25 it says under this section from
acting as a participant at a sports
event and when you were discussing it
you were discussing it in the context
of coming as an attendee and I just
wanted to ask in your opinion as an
attorney do you think that it's clear
that we're not that the language that's
used doesn't just mean from acting as
like a participant in the sporting event
and that it actually means
means you know being an attendee as well
or do you think that that language
should be clarified a little bit well if
you look up at uh number 11 uh and I'm
sure Kevin had discussed this when he
spoke with Senator delandro participant
has been defined in its uh pretty uh
allinclusive okay thank you sure right
representative Wallace thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
have you considered um a single parent
family with a student athlete being
banned and what uh negative impact this
would have on parental rights in that
set of circumstances and what do you
think the response is going to be in
that situation I've thought about it but
by the way I just want to say paretic I
I'm I hope I live long enough so I'm in
court and the judge says to me um thank
you for uh answering my question or
taking my question attorney to do
uh this this is this this is how I would
answer your question the parent is not
being penalized because they're a single
parent the parent is being penalized for
what they have done they've committed a
crime so think of it this way so the
parent goes to a the parent goes to a
wedding drinks a little bit too much
gets caught for drunk driving and ends
up losing his or her license either for
drunk driving or reckless driving and
then the parents said well GE wi I'm a
single parent I can't take my kids to to
the games and I can't take my kids to
practice
that's not fair to my kid right it isn't
fair to your kid and it's not fair to
your kid because of what you did you
broke the
law so maybe if people are worried about
that they'll act
better or they'll get their friends to
drive them but you know every every
criminal prosecution has a
consequence um to the victim and to the
defendant and that's that that's just
the process that we have
you about follow up sure thank you uh in
the um example that you gave uh would
you agree that um an individual having
too much to drink and driving on the
public roads is a hazard to the general
public where the individual in this
particular bill would be maybe uh you
know aggressive or assaulting to one
individual oh sure they're different
yeah they difference in in degrees I
think I was looking at the language here
the way the language is written in
paragraph
three
um I I don't think it's mandatory it
says in addition the court May prohibit
it's May right so you think the Optics
of it be uh problematic you know
prohibiting parents from attending their
kids games well well I think if there's
a compelling reason like if it's an if
it's an an adoration a person has lived
a good life he's never been a problem uh
if he's going through some stresses he
get he gets you to the game and then the
referee's walking by and grabs his
shoulder and says hey you know you're
gonna my kid this is important you know
you know I get that it's not right I get
I get that so maybe when he's sentenced
the judge says yeah I'm not going to
prevent you from going to your kids game
but if but if the next guy comes in and
he's been a problem the whole year I
think you treat him differently and
that's the way the system work so there
there's your safety valve right
there thank you sure other other
questions seeing none thank you very
much attorney toas I great seeing you
again you too can I leave the packet yes
absolutely please if you would give it
to representative Ming on the end there
he'll pass it down and I've only got one
I didn't know how many make that's okay
we'll we'll we can get
copies
is there anyone else um who wishes to
testify on uh Senate Bill
327 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill
327 and uh since we're after 11:30 I'm
going to open the hearing uh on Senate
Bill
361 uh and repes uh recognize the prime
sponsor Senator Carson Mr chair I have a
pink card may I approach yeah or you
could just give it to repres pres me and
he'll pass it down thank thank
you good morning Mr chairman and
honorable members of house Judiciary for
the record my name is Sharon Carson and
I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of londondary Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration this morning
Senate Bill uh what are we looking at
here uh
361 which uh seeks to extend the par
professional pilot program by five years
and extends it to all courts um Mr
chairman this bill does two things it
extends the project by five years and
and expands it to all district Division
and Family Division locations currently
the program is located in Manchester
Berlin and
Franklin um we've gotten some initial
feedback from the uh from the pilot and
it really was a small but meaningful
step for better access to justice for
lowincome granite Staters it limits the
scope to certain civil cases involving
domestic violence stalking certain
family law cases and certain housing uh
case types and it continues to ensure
that par professional representation is
high quality and consistent with legal
ethic things um we had a very uh robust
Hearing in that in the Senate I learned
that again it's it's working and it's
working very well we did put in an
amendment um because there was a
question concerning um a report that was
due and the committee Senate Judiciary
felt that it was important that we be
able to keep tabs on this program um we
made the
2025 report an interm report and then we
required a report at the end of the
5-year period which I believe is
2029 um at that point Mr chair at this
point I will conclude my testimony
there's uh folks here from the court
system as well as legal aid to talk
about how successful this program is and
so I will conclude my testimony thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you any
questions for the
senator great thank you very much thank
you very much Mr chairman and good day
to all the committee members
next I'm going to call on uh uh Supreme
Court Justice Jim Basset welcome thank
you very
much great to see you great to see you
yeah great to see all of you
um uh good morning Mr chairman and uh
members of the committee um for the
record my name is Jim Basset I'm senior
associate
Justice at the New Hampshire Supreme
Court I've been on the Court uh for 12
years uh during that time I've also been
the Court's leaz on and representative
on the access to Justice Commission and
for the past five years I've been the
co-chairman of the access to Justice
Commission so these issues that we're
here to speak about today are near and
dear to my heart I'm speaking on behalf
of our court on behalf of the judicial
branch and also on behalf of the access
to Justice Commission that work closely
with New Hampshire legal assistance in
originally developing and promoting the
idea that's embodied in this legislation
and was
embodied in-house Bill 1343 two years
ago which was groundbreaking legislation
to establish a pilot program permitting
par professionals to provide Legal
Services Under supervision of a licensed
attorney the effective date was January
1 uh 2023
and that bill itself was the product of
considerable uh work and Del
deliberative process uh in many branches
particularly over in the legislature um
there was a study committee I know
representative uh judge Senator Gordon
is here I know he was very involved
through that process it couldn't have
happened without him uh the access to
Justice Commission supported the
development of the um in the study
committee and the
legislation and then uh after passage of
the U Bill uh we had to undertake uh
rulemaking at the court in order to make
this possible but all of that happened
so that it was in effect January of
2023 uh as um Senator Carson said this
bill would extend the sunset de Sunset
date to 2030 and expand the program to
Statewide to all the circuit
courts um we we at the court urge
approval for three reasons first um in
the first year it has been an operation
the pilot has shown promise based on
reports filed with our court the program
has been used in 11 cases I think uh the
executive director of New Hampshire
legal assistants can update those
numbers when she
testified uh on based on the data that
we have those cases involve were
domestic violence cases um Circuit Court
administrative judge king reports that
all has gone smoothly and one of our
Circuit Court judges Kim shabo has
conducted several hearings involving PA
professionals she reports that they've G
done a good job and that their presence
has been beneficial to the court and to
the litigant second as promising as the
initial reports are uh we believe it
would be better to have more experience
before we make a
recommendation as to what should come
next uh we would particularly like to
have more experience in other case types
including marital parenting and landlord
tenant and third the need that inspired
this
legislation the a the access to Justice
gap between those who who need legal
representation and those who cannot have
it remains U achingly large as ever only
about 15% of the litigants in our
circuit courts have legal representation
and considering that there are
approximately 12,000 filings in the
Circuit Court every year the numbers of
self-represented litigant are
staggering but the sum of uh those
numbers uh doesn't really reflect the
basic human needs and they're that these
people are operating with an un in an
unfamiliar system and need assistance
and this is one way to do it the access
to Justice Commission is taking a
holistic view of the self-represented
litigant issue we have lots of different
initiatives right now but this is a very
important one so thanks to this
legislation um in about 10 or so
instances during the past year and three
months two months a victim of domestic
violence was there with a trained
professional providing assistance when
that would not have otherwise been the
case we uh did suggest in the Senate and
the Senate did adopt the amendment to
have the 2025 report be an interim
report and the final report uh when we
have much more data and experience be in
2029 so I'm here to voice the
wholehearted support of the access to
Justice Commission and the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and I'm happy to answer
any
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much Mr chairman nice to
see you again nice to see you next I'm G
to call on uh uh Ned Gordon Please Mr
chair while the former chair is
approaching I do want to congratulate
the previous speaker on getting your
title
[Laughter]
right thank
you Mr Gordon welcome thank you members
of the committee and my name is Ned
Gordon I live in
Bristol and I am a retired circuit court
judge I sat in the circuit court for 13
years 12 years I served as a family
court judge I was one of the first
judges to volunteer for the Family Court
after it was integrated into the Circuit
Court um I think this is a very
important bill I sponsored the original
Bill uh creating the pilot
program I think uh you've already heard
the reasons uh well well spoken by the
senator and
Justice I think another five years would
be great I think one of the things I'd
like to see is right now legal
assistance has been providing these
types of services is I'd like to see if
we had a 5-year window perhaps some
private
practitioners uh being involved as well
I think that that would be uh uh
interesting and I'd like to have the
opportunity to see that happen I think
the whole I think we can all agree that
the one thing that we want our court
systems to do is to to provide Justice
and right now we have we have this
structure this uh Paradigm this uh we
have attorneys and we have
paralegals and unfortunately what we've
doing right now from my perspective is
we're trying to make Justice fit this
professional
structure and I think what we're trying
to do or what the effort is made with
regard to this particular pilot program
is to try to make the structure provide
for
justice and I think we can look at the
um medical profession probably as a good
example because they had a structure a
paradigm they had doctors and nurses and
50 years ago and what they did was say
over time what they've come to learn is
that uh what you do is you should make
people's
qualifications fit fit the skills that
are needed to do a particular
job and we're not doing a good job at
that in the medical industry what they
did do they had doctors and nurses now
they have nurse practitioners they have
Physicians
assistants they have a whole structure
who thought 20 years ago your pharmacist
would be giving you your
shots the fact is that you try to match
skill level with what uh is required and
I think this is the direction that the
legal profession needs to go in and it's
the direction our courts need to go in
and I think the pilot program is an
effort to begin that process to make
that happen to make that work and I just
encourage you to support the bill I
think it's in uh the state's best
interest and the populations the state
best interest and thank you very much
thank you questions U representative
Kat thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I see in the
original Statue that court
rules kind dictate the manage of
practice so I I guess I'm wondering does
that I know you mentioned currently that
the par professionals are practicing
under New Hampshire legal aid do the
court rules established currently that
it has to be under New Hampshire legal
aid or does it currently allow for
private attorneys to allow par
professionals but they're just not
currently doing so uh it allows for uh
for paralegals to practice under the
offices of an attorney it's not limited
to
Services other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Mr Gordon thank you thank you for being
here next I'm going to call on uh Donnie
shed
please good morning chairman Lynn
members of the committee my name is
Donnie shed and I am the current
president of the paralal association of
New Hampshire
excuse me established in
1983 p is a Statewide nonprofit
voluntary professional association
comprised of pargal law firms schools
and other organizations dedicated to the
development of the paralal profession
here in New
Hampshire excuse me I'm a paralal I'm
usually behind the scenes so being in
front of everybody is not something I'm
familiar with uh p& offers professional
development networking opportunities to
our members continuing legal education
events as well as serving as a resource
and advocate for our members and our
community regarding the paralal
profession with our state Mission being
the development of the paralal
profession here in New Hampshire I'm
here today to speak on behalf of the
more than 100 members of P&H to voice
our support for the passage of Senate
Bill 361 in the extension and expansion
of the current paraprofessional pilot
program p& has supported and championed
this program since its infancy and we
will continue to do so as this program
grows throughout our state like you we
are well aware of the continued need to
ensure access to justice for
self-represented litigants and others
who require both legal advice and
functional practical support in
navigating our court systems
additionally we at P&H keep an eye on
Trends in the paralal profession
Nationwide it is clear that New
Hampshire has been at the Forefront of
was what is becoming a nationwide trend
of States creating similar pilot
programs for their own paraprofessionals
and paralegals these programs are the
future and by passing this bill today
you are ensuring that New Hampshire
remains in step with other states around
the country you set a model for other
states to follow and you are ensuring
that highly qualified well-educated
non-lawyer legal professionals such as
myself are able to use our training and
professional experience to assist those
who need it most so I thank you for your
time and it's my sincerest hope that
you'll pass this Bill thank you thank
you very much there questions for this
witness yes representative Manos thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I was wondering the bill refers
to par professionals and I was wondering
the distinction between par
professionals and paral
leals I think it depends on the context
uh a non- lawyer Legal Professional
could be a legal assistant um or a
pargal I think the difference comes in
the sense that
as paralegals we have certain ethical
obligations that we have to meet that
legal assistants don't as well as our
Education and Training are usually a
little bit
higher followup thank you so is it your
understanding that this bill is that the
use of par professionals actually refers
to means paral leals rather than a legal
assistant I believe the bill does state
um paralegals I'm not uh familiar with
the exact terminology um in that context
but I would assume that based upon the
educational requirements and things like
that the bill is referring to
paralegals yeah please go
ahead so it's under RSA 311 colon 2-a
that a par professional either has a
bachelor's degree in any field or an
associates degree in a law law related
field
and at least 2 years of work experience
in a Law related setting with attorney
supervision so that's how it's defined
in
here could you just repeat the the
citation yeah 311 colon 2- a I think
it's a little confusing because this
names the chapter and then you have to
go and find the chapter of the bill to
find the statute
number all right other questions for
this we
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you very much for your
time next I'm going to call on Sarah
Matson Dustin
please thank you Mr chair good afternoon
to the committee my name is Sarah Matson
Dustin I work as the executive director
at New Hampshire legal assistance for
those who aren't familiar we're a
nonprofit Law Firm a legal aid provider
we help people who have low income with
cases civil cases impacting their basic
needs the bulk of the work that we do is
in the areas of housing domestic
violence and domestic violence related
family law we're here in very
enthusiastic support of Senate Bill
361 I think I can put a little more meat
on the bones actually and answer to
representative mano's question the term
paralal um broadly speaking in New
Hampshire is not not one that is defined
either by Statute or by Court rule um so
the term par professional here exists
only in so far as it is designed it's
defined for this paralal project this
par professional pilot
project
um many of the of the previous Witnesses
said what I had planned to so I won't
repeat that I suspect I'm also standing
between you and lunch um way back when
the legislature first started
considering this in a study committee in
2019 there were very tiny handful of
states around the country that were
doing anything related to expanding the
scope of practice for non- lawyers now
there are nine states that have
implemented projects there are another
half dozen plus who are actively
considering it the most recent state to
make significant progress toward
expanding access to Legal Services
through par professionals is Texas um
which has a um a recommendation pending
before its Supreme Court right now to
implement a project and states do this
in all different ways uh there's one
threshold question though that every
state who is thinking about this has to
answer in the first instance and that is
whether they're going to have a model
that requires attorney supervision or a
model that doesn't um and New
Hampshire's pilot is very squarely in
the category of requiring attorney
supervision um which I think has made a
lot of sense for New Hampshire it means
that there doesn't need to be a separate
regulatory structure a separate
licensing structure a separate
disciplinary structure
um requires for example attorneys to
make sure that their pa of professionals
that they're supervising are covered by
their professional liability insurance
um so it's just a it's a very smart way
of EXA of leveraging the structure that
already
exists uh I've worked at nhla for about
16 years in total and in those 16 years
there has not been a week that has gone
by that we have not turned someone away
because we don't have enough staff to
help them and so for us using the
services other of par of professionals
other than attorneys has always been
part of our law practice because this is
something that is is permitted in
settings other than the courtroom so
just to give you some examples um in
administrative law cases so for example
when someone um is appealing the denial
of a public benefit um you don't have to
be represented by a lawyer in those
cases there are certain units of federal
government which specifically authorize
practice practice by non- attorneys so
we have on our staff um a
paraprofessional who's authorized to
practice before the Social Security
Administration we have a par
professional who's authorized to
practice in certain kinds of immigration
proceedings um so for for us um having
folks who aren't attorneys helping
clients and having in place systems to
supervise them has been the case for
long as long as we've been around um but
until this pilot project there has
always been this invisible line around
the courthouse
where a paralal shall not pass and we
know from our experience having
paraprofessionals handle incredibly
complex disability appeals immigration
proceedings um that par professionals
absolutely have the knowledge and the
skills to be able to represent people um
with appropriate attorney supervision um
hearing the the statistics that you
heard today about how many people go to
court without lawyers um
meant that there was a real opportunity
here to solve a problem with something
other than more
lawyers I feel really strongly that we
are not going to solve the access to
Justice Gap with just more attorneys um
and the courts I think are doing a
terrific job in thinking about this from
a variety of different perspectives um
it's also great to make the court system
easier to navigate on your own and
that's something that our judicial
branch has has taken really seriously um
but this pilot project in my experience
has been the most significant innovation
in terms of solving the problem of
access to representation um we have
handled 16 cases since the pilot began
that we would not have been able to take
otherwise we have prioritized paralal
hiring over the past two years in order
we hope to be able to continue utilizing
the services of attorneys other of
people other than attorneys to help our
clients um so uh really really
enthusiastic about it hope that this
committee um which has really been part
of this since the outset will continue
to support it and I'd be very happy to
answer any questions thank you questions
for this witness representative Manos
thank you Mr chair and thank you
question I was wondering if you could
just talk a little bit more about
attorney supervision and what exactly
that entails and is this a paralal going
to court and then making evidentiary
objections so it the pilot project does
specifically authorize courtroom
representation um so that could uh
absolutely require both um the
submission of evidence and the making of
of evidentiary objections that is
certainly the case um attorney
supervision there is in some ways
defined by the Court rule I put a copy
of the Court rule in your packets um so
everyone has that it's Supreme Court
rule
um the attorney the attorney obligation
to supervised non-attorneys in one's law
practice existed before this pilot
project and before rule 35 so if you
think for example about real estate
transacting um if you've ever been to a
real estate closing at a lawyer's office
um you very likely even sat with a
paralal and it's incredibly likely that
a paralal had a significant role in the
preparation of the documents for the
closing it would not be particularly
cost effective um for attorneys to be
doing work that can be done um by
paralegals and build out at their
clients to a lower rate so um law firms
have always had to have systems in place
in order to supervise the non-attorneys
in their office um every Law Firm is
going to set up that supervisory system
in a slightly different way um we have
our systems that we use to supervise not
only uh non-attorneys but also to
supervise Junior attorneys um who are
are very new to law practice um
the the the pilot project itself um has
very little by way of saying this is how
you must supervise um and really um
requires the attorney to make
appropriate judgment calls about what a
particular par illegal is going to need
so just to give you an example on the
first day that an attorney Works in our
office we're not going to send that
attorney to court by themselves um much
less a paralal um but there are
experienced paralegals who are very
knowledgeable in a particular practice
area and have observed many many
hearings sitting next to an attorney who
for whom it may be appropriate um in
certain cases for them to um to appear
on their own so it um again it it's
utilizing the existing system of
supervision that was already required by
our ethical
rules other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you um is there anyone else who uh
wishes to testify on uh Senate Bill
361 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill
361 um and um I just briefly uh
discussed this with uh representative
Smith um my inclination is that this is
something we could just exec now is
anybody uh anybody have any problem with
doing I believe representative Smith
agrees but I'm I I should ask her for
sure yes Mr chair I agree anybody have
any problem if we exec this bill
now all right so um then um do I have a
motion uh I'll move all right so moved
by representative Smith seconded by
representative katab um any any further
discussion I I mean I just speaking
personally I think based on what Justice
Basset said and Justice Gordon and
really all the witnesses I mean it seems
like this is absolutely worth doing and
uh um I think that the the practice of
law is moving in the direction that they
indicated and I think that's that's a
good
thing any yes representative Wallace
thank you cherland uh well we have a
couple of nurses on the committee and I
think in their Community uh the medical
uh world the nurses do the bulk of the
work and I would argue that the
paralegals do the bulk of the work in in
the judicial world so uh to will be
supporting this any other yes uh
representative Lono I just wanted to say
uh thank you for letting me make a
comment um as a nurse I think uh it's
really good to see that there'd be more
representation um to help with the court
systems um but I think um just wondering
too the liability I've I didn't I didn't
quite hear that about the liability in
regards to um who is do they have their
own uh liability or does that uh the
paay professional fall under the lawyer
I can I think I can answer that unless
you'd rather have if we're in executive
session right oh right but if sure now
if you have the answer that's fine and
if I assume if somebody in the audience
disagrees with you they'll let us know
oh I know that um uh it is my
understanding Mr chair that as part of
this project the um I'll use the word
sponsor you know whether
it's uh legal aid or whatever has the
responsibility to
um provide uh the liability
coverage I've been on this issue for a
long time Mr chair seeing no no
objection from the audience I I accept
that what you say is true um all right
well thank you for that vote of
confidence
any uh yes representative Manos and then
representative Oregon I I had one
question that I that I neglected to ask
but maybe maybe you know um when a
paralal participates in a case and an
appearance is filed do they file their
own appearance and does the court then
know that representation is being
provided by a paralal as opposed to an
attorney or is it the appearance of the
attorney that is technically on record
if if I remember correctly and again I
please correct me if I'm wrong um the uh
the par
professional whatever the title is um
enters his or her appearance and is
noted for what that person's
qualifications
are representative Oregon I was just
going to comment this bill takes effect
on passage I.E when we send it around
and it gets over to the governor's desk
so the sooner this process uh is
completed assuming the Full House agrees
with us this is a good bill the sooner
goes to the Secretary State and the
governor then the sooner it gets passed
and the sooner um New Hampshire legal
assistance and the other entities are
making use of it can begin uh planning
their their cases because uh it makes a
difference if this is going to end
January 1st 2025 or where they have
another four years to uh to take
advantage of this and maybe even
permanently so I think you know the
sooner we can get this through the
process uh the better for everyone
involved thanks any other comments from
yes representative D Lorenzo uh thank
you Mr chair and um I do want to say
that I studied to be a paralal um back
in the 80s I went to the University of
Massachusetts in uh Boston and we had a
program it was called um legal studies
major and we were preparing to be become
paralegals so after graduated from uh
UMass I went on to Boston University and
I completed their program um it was
called Boston University program for
Legal Assistant so sometimes the terms
are use interchangeably I ended up in
housing though rather than being a
paralal but I found that in my housing
work I got there was plenty of
opportunity to work on a lot of things
but I think it's a great program and I'm
really excited about it thank you all
right any other any other comments all
right so I think we're ready then to
call the role uh the motion is uh ought
to pass Vice chairman Wallace
yes rep testerman yes rep trip yes clerk
atab votes yes rep Smith
yes rep Horgan yes rep dorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep lonza
yes rep Mana
yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 12 to
Z all right um consent can this go on
there's a got an FN but I think it
probably can going
yeah yeah
pardon okay so yeah so good all right so
consent all right and you'll do the
report to re Smith okay thank you great
all right um with that I think we can
take the lunch break and we'll resume at
one o'clock thank you very much uh
everyone
for
e
all right um it's um 1 p.m. or that's
after 1 p.m. I'm going to call the uh
hearing on Senate Bill
435 um and I will recognize Senator
delandro the prime sponsor of the
bill Mr chair
and U thank you members of the committee
uh I was here this morning so if I
repeat myself I apologize I'm Senator
lud alesandro I represent District 20
Manchester Woods 2 three and four 10 11
and 12 and I come before you as the
prime sponsor of Senate Bill
435 relative to the New Hampshire
unitrust
statute now for those of you who have
been around here here for a while uh I
sponsored the initial trust legislation
almost 20 years ago and uh what we were
trying to do was develop the best trust
laws in the United
States and we were in competition with
Dakota and Delaware not Dakota or
Delaware so what we did is we we brought
forth a series of changes to trust to
trust law and in this particular bill is
an upgrade of of what we had there were
very very few changes a lot of lot of
movement as far as the statutes are
concerned Yona uh and the uh the
movement is the placement uh the
placement of of of certain U uh certain
items in in different spots and Glen
Glen PLO from uh the trust company will
be here to go over each and every one of
those details with you but Senate Bill
435 continues to improve New Hampshire's
worldclass environment for trusts and
Trust Services providing settlers and
their advisers with a menu of
cuttingedge estate planning techniques
while making new hamp's trust laws as
clear and user friendly as
possible um it was adopted by the Senate
with minor uh amendments and we had a
series of bills that have come in over a
period of time there are three major
components of this bill and as I said Mr
Perlo will go over with you all of these
in in detail it's the movement of of U
certain things from one from blind to
another the the original amendment that
we made in in the house just corrected a
statutory reference from from B to from
A to B in terms of the statute uh he'll
go into more detail of what's in in this
bill uh this bill cleans up and
simplifies the trust statutes by
correcting errors and moving relevant
portions of RSA 564a into RSA
564b the New Hampshire trust code and
repealing the remainder of rsas
564a period RSA 564a has served as New
Hampshire's original trust code but over
the years following the adoption of The
Bard New Hampshire trust code most of
the except exceptions have been repealed
leaving only a few stray Provisions
further consolidating the state's trust
laws into the Noy trust code will make
these laws clearer and more
understandable and more user friendly
and uh Mr plar will give you a a
thorough analysis of that and as I said
over the years we have become extremely
competitive for non-depository trusts we
we they've located in the State uh it's
been a job creation
situation uh
Jordan park has now relocated in U in
Portsmouth they've got an office in
Portsmouth um a number of people working
out of out of that office and they they
are integral part of the trust uh trust
business here in the state of New New
Hampshire so with that Mr chairman uh
the specific details could be gone over
uh by those who are intricately involved
in the trust business in New Hampshire
the purpose of the trust legislation
initially was job creation bring more
business to to New Hampshire locate more
trust in in in New Hampshire and create
a vibrant economy as far as trusts are
concerned and we've done that over the
years that business has expanded and uh
Mr pear can give you more more detail
about that so with that I'll try to
address any any questions that that that
you may have and uh Mr will go in and
fill in the blankes so to speak great
thank you Senator questions for Senator
delis
Sandra seeing none thank you very much
sir oh you're very welcome thank you
thank you for your attention have a
great day thank you uh Mr PLO and you
know Mr Perlo can I just ask you to fill
out a pink card if you would yeah you
don't
have great if you just give it to
representative Oregon he'll pass it down
thank you and if you don't mind Mr ch I
like to be joined by my friend and
colleag sure
really absolutely come on up also um I
am uh handing out uh some proposed
revisions okay trying to make a good
thing
better no no that's fine sure that's
fine no
problem of this
proposal
two
section okay okay
great all right so you know what can I
just U Mr Pearl can I just ask you the
the um the proposed amendments that you
just gave me so I see that though you
the way you've done it is um amend the
bill by replacing all so this if we give
this to OS and say just you know make
this do do this and put it in final form
that will that will be the whole
Amendment uh we you won't you won't have
to refer back to the original Bill no
okay all right great hopefully that is a
helpful way yeah no no it's a very
helpful way to do uh because there were
changes in a few places though not you
know very significant yeah no that's a
very that's a very helpful way to do
it so uh I'll introduce myself uh my
name is Glenn PLO uh as Senator Del Sor
kindly said I've been working in this
space for a very long time I'm General
council at Jordan Park Trust Company in
Portsmouth um and I'm also president of
the trust Council and for those of you
who don't uh know the work of the trust
Council uh building on what uh the
senator said um no State can continue
successfully sort of competing in this
uh Arena without continuously ensuring
that uh if better Mouse trrap shows up
somewhere else or if just someone comes
along with a better idea that we care
and feed this modernization uh because
it's not a static sort of an industry
and so uh with tremendous support from
the legislature for nearly 20 years uh
we we've done that and we've we we've
tried to improve where we can um and uh
and we appreciate all that support we
have a legislative committee with a a
number of experienced trust
practitioners
um whenever we have some notion about
legislation we go to uh all the
stakeholders we think would have any
interest in it so all of this has been
uh reviewed by the banking Department
the bankers Association uh the director
of charitable trust which whom we've had
some dialogue I don't uh speak to their
positions on the bill but we have um
shared it out and had dialogue uh back
and forth uh with that Patrick is uh is
uh
Patrick Collins is a director at mlan
Middleton in the trust and States
Department he chairs uh the council's
legislative committee uh he's the best
trust practitioner I've ever met and my
friend uh and uh he'll go over and you
know we're prepared at whatever 100,000
feet 25,000 fet any questions Patrick
will be able to uh walk you through so
he'll start with a kind of a high level
walk through and uh we'll take it from
there that no that'd be great if you yes
uh welcome and if you could just uh
maybe just kind of give us give the
committee sort of just an overview of
what is a unit trust and you know that
that kind of thing perfect we'll do uh
thanks for having me here the uh big
picture overview of what we're trying to
achieve is three things um and I'll just
classify them kind of uh casually as
we're trying to clean up we're trying to
clarify and we're trying to optimize and
then there are three buckets into which
those fall so the first is uh we have uh
as part of the New Hampshire trust code
uh the statutory uh language there is
under 564b and that was part of the
modernization that Senator delandre was
was mentioning uh and so when any of a
time a practitioner is looking to see
what is allowed what does the statute
provide for they go to
564b historically the uh trust laws
prior to the enactment of the New
Hampshire trust code were kind of
scattered throughout the various other
statutes uh and one place where uh some
old language still exists in
564a and so one of the cleanups that
we're doing is taking the language
that's in 564a and moving it into 564b
just so that practitioners when they're
looking to see anything related to trust
there's one place to go and that's 564b
and not hanging out there other
statutory Provisions that are directly
related so that's not a very substantive
change it's really just a migration
that's the cleanup um for um
optimization uh we have in our statute
um the ability to convert uh a trust uh
to a unit trust which I'm going to
describe in a second what we don't have
is the ability at Inception of a trust
creation to create a unit trust and so
when we were thinking about well we have
we have the ability to convert to it why
don't we just have the ability to do it
from the beginning uh and I'll explain
what that what that means um in a second
uh and then thirdly we have uh a
clarification uh Amendment to the trust
code which is uh specifically around the
liability and the responsibility and the
duties of Trustees uh to redress
breaches of trust that are known uh and
I'll I'll get into that in more detail
so those are the two substantive changes
the first on the
unitrust um a uh to to describe what a
unitrust is I'm going to describe what
uh traditional trust law looks like in
terms of distribution requirements um
generally speaking traditionally uh
trusts usually would
bifurcate uh interests that a
beneficiary could have into an income
interest and a principal interest and so
if you have Assets in a trust uh they
typically hopefully will generate income
so that would be that would be dividends
on stocks interest on bank accounts uh
rental income if you has real estate
that income interest traditionally uh
could be assigned to a specific
beneficiary so for example you might say
on my death when I pass away I leave x
amount of money in trust for my wife and
my wife can get all of the income from
the trust and that would be all that
income that the trust generates after my
wife dies what's left all the principle
which is the Corpus of the Trust might
go to my kids that would be a kind of a
standard uh example of a of a trust term
what ended up happening by virtue of
that traditional structure is that
Investments uh ended up being tailored
more towards generating income because
that was the def
benefit that the that the beneficiary
the income beneficiary had and so the
Investment Portfolio would look
something like investments in non-growth
stocks that generated income whether
that's uh you know like a utility
company or Verizon that kicks off a
pretty healthy dividend so that the
income beneficiary had a sufficient
amount of cash flow that they could
receive by virtue of doing that that
hurt to some extent the remainder
beneficiaries which would be the kids in
that example uh because they are subject
to a an Investment Portfolio that's not
really built to grow but just to
generate income and so uh not us uh but
in the general realm of trust and
Estates planning uh the idea of a unit
trust was born which was to say instead
of focusing on income which then derives
you know a specific Investment Portfolio
can we instead give that income
beneficiary a right to a percentage of
the trust and thereby allow the trust
Investments to be uh tailored more
towards growth and so if you had
somebody over the last 10 or 15 years uh
that was invested in more growth stocks
like Apple and Google and Nidia you know
you would see a much better return than
if you were invested in income uh
producing stocks and by virtue of that
uh the unit trust statutes were born uh
and in New Hampshire what we currently
have is the ability to take one of those
traditional trusts that was income based
and convert it to a unit trust which
would allow the the spouse in that
example to instead of receiving income
receive between three and 5% of the
trust Corpus each year valued at as of
uh December 31st of the prior year and
so by virtue that the the the the
profile of the assets increases this the
income beneficiary actually ends up
getting more and the remainder
beneficiary gets more assuming that the
uh assuming that the the assets in the
trust grow uh which which they should um
and so we have that already baked into
our statute that's already there what
we're asking for with this amendment is
to authorize a uh trust at Inception to
be structured as a unit trust whereby
the uh one individual would be the
recipient of a percentage of the trust
uh which we're gauging between three and
5% um as opposed to just being defined
by income um it's it's a provision that
is in uh Delaware statute uh we just
don't have it here it's not a uh we
don't think at least a a major
substantive change it's just an
optionality uh that we don't currently
have uh to start at Inception um in a
unit trust structure and we think it's
uh beneficial to all involved uh both
the current individual beneficiaries who
had theoretically received more uh in a
in a trust that was growing and uh and
the remainder beneficiaries who would
also benefit uh from a growth uh growth
structured uh portfolio as well and it's
fairly common I should add that um the
remainder beneficiaries are charitable
uh institutions or otherwise that's that
that's a fairly typical way to use a
unit so I think there's some benefit
there to be able to do that right at the
outset
okay um so so that's the second piece
the third one uh is uh a clarification
um and this is a completely different
section of the trust code um uh and
requires a little bit of background so
bear with me for a couple minutes to
kind of explain this uh uh in a
traditional trust uh the governance of a
trust is is uh the responsibility of a
trustee and very big picture a trustee
has three fundamental responsibilities
one is to decide on distributions to the
beneficiaries uh and that could you know
deciding when how much for what purpose
to make distributions to the
beneficiaries in ordance with the terms
of the trust document that's one of the
fundamental Powers distributions the
second is to decide on investments how
to invest the Assets in the trust uh to
preserve the Corpus grow it um and and
generally speaking be fully in charge
and cloaked with all the powers on the
investment side and then the third is to
handle all the administrative
responsibilities uh that a trust
requires that's your bookkeeping your
accounting recordkeeping paying taxes so
on and so forth um in New Hampshire as
part of the modernization uh that uh
Senator delandra referenced uh we have
taken those three powers of uh of a
trustee and allowed for people to
bifurcate those into their own uh
component parts and so by virtue of that
you could have a governance structure
where you have one person who's maybe
close to the family who's in charge of
distributions only that's all they're
responsible for they don't have anything
to do with Investments they have nothing
to do with the uh the administ ative
Powers all they're deciding as when for
what purpose um and the amount to
distribute to beneficiaries second
sliver is the Investments that's all
they're responsible for is the
Investments and then the third is the
administrative functions and that's
where a lot of trust companies like
Jordan Park Trust Company um now iqq
trust company uh have borne out and
that's where we have a really powerful
industry um created a lot of jobs in New
Hampshire through uh trust companies
serving in that administrative function
only what was
uh uh part of the statutory scheme in
order to develop that uh and to get
trust uh the the people serving in their
various component parts comfortable in
serving in those roles uh was a
provision in the code that says that you
are only responsible for your component
part if you are respon if you're
responsible for distributions and the
Investments are handled poorly you're
not responsible for that you can't be
brought to brought to bear for the
responsibility of someone else even
though you're all collectively part of
the same trust instrument
um uh and that gave everybody comfort
that okay I'm I'm only responsible for
my component part I'm not responsible
for others and I'm I'm therefore willing
to do
this when we went through as we do every
year uh trying to make sure that our
trust code is optimized and modernized
we recognized that there was a uh an
absence of clarity as to a specific
aspect of trust Administration that
could arise in that divided trust
governance and that is if I am the
um if I am the investment director say
I'm solely in charge of Investments and
the distribution director who's in
charge of just distributions say the
distribution director uh uh makes a
distribution to somebody who is not a
beneficiary that would be a serious
breach of trust and if I know about that
even though I'm not responsible for that
person's actions do I have a duty to
redress it do I have a duty to try to
either Sue or bring some kind of action
to redress that that uh that breach of
of trust and where we try to draw the
line uh so that people are um keeping a
general overview of what's going on with
the trust RIT large but not necessarily
being responsible for what other people
are doing is we said if there is a
serious breach of trust serious being
the component word uh or the important
word uh then you are responsible as the
as a fiduciary of that trust to try to
redress that breach so if there's a
serious breach you are responsible to
try to fix it but if there's just a
general breach uh that that is that just
happens in the ordinary course we don't
want to have the administrative trustee
be on the hook for having to sue their
co- fiduciary uh for a breach that would
be the responsibility of the beneficiary
the person who is ultimately receiving
the benefit of the trust uh to to
redress if they thought it was necessary
to do so and leaving it to their hands
to to to bring up uh lawsuits if there
was an issue but not as between the
fiduciaries themselves um that was not
clearly laid out in the statute uh and
so part of our clarification here is to
say that a divided
truste uh is responsible to clar to
redress breaches of trust if there is a
serious breach but not responsible uh to
sue their co-trustees if it's just a
regular breach and that that Duty would
fall instead to the beneficiary uh who's
the one that's ultimately receiving the
benefit and would be most interested in
um making sure that there aren't
breaches so sorry that was a longwinded
way of of kind of highlighting the big
three and happy to answer any questions
maybe I can just throw oh please go
first oh could you thank you could use
the microphone please thank if you found
that a a produci had not not followed
their the rules
and you were another
fiduciary um would you be responsible
for telling the the owner of the
trust uh I found this I'm not going to
do anything about it but you need to be
aware that I found
this great question and in the current
trust uh statute uh there is actually
spec spec specific language on that
piece and um it provides and this is
under um uh not that you probably this
under Section 124 and it says that a uh
fiduciary who's only responsible for one
aspect has no Duty uh with respect to
those serving in another capacity to
monitor their conduct to uh advise the
other trustees uh or the beneficiaries
of their conduct uh or to communicate or
warn the beneficiaries of any um uh
potential concerning issues that might
arise and so by virtue of that in the
industry we have always kind of assumed
that by virtue of those very limited um
obligations with respect to dealing with
your co- fiduciaries uh that there was
no duty to redress a breach um I'm
responsible for my conduct and my
conduct alone I don't have to deal with
what the others are doing the
beneficiaries ultimately will deal with
them if there's an issue that arises and
so the circumstance here that was
somewhat uh unclear but that pops up
every now and again is what if you
actually become aware of it I know have
no duty to advise I have no duty to
monitor I have no duty to communicate
but what if I know about it and what we
were saying is that if you know about it
and it's a serious breach then you
should you should be responsible for
having to fix it or at least try to fix
it if it's just a if it's just a you
know a a a minor breach leave it to the
beneficiaries to decide whether or not
to incur the cost and the time and
expense of of uh trying to redress
it if I may without being tooo cial
about it um it's a Brother's Keeper kind
of a setup which allows for people as
Patrick said to have the Comfort level
to serve in a in a a very narrow
capacity um but you know at the same
time there's always an underlying
fiduciary duty you know to do the right
thing as a trustee so I can imagine any
circumstances where you might well
advise this is more about like do you
actually have to go you know for the
beneficiaries sake and bring a loss suit
or otherwise take extraordinary steps
and
so the balance is to allow trustees to
do what we've given them the power to do
for settlers which is to Avail
themselves of this very structure
without kind of being in a
catch22 um where they're treated for
liability purposes as if they were a
full Trustee of all aspects but they
really don't have the power um and or
necessarily the reach to even know
what exactly is going on with an
administrative with a investment advisor
say and this is what you know these are
Arrangements that our clients come to us
for uh because they have a preferred
investment advisor already or because
they have a good friend who's going to
serve in this or that capacity or they
want um family members to make decisions
about beneficiaries that sort of thing
so it's really a matter of trying to
strike an appropriate balance where
beneficiaries aren't left without re
recourse and no one is looking out for
anything but it uh it invites
practitioners to engage in in in all of
this questions for this witness yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question I'm
confused about the unitary trust and I
wanted to hear more about that and
specifically I was confused about the
example you used of the Widow and the
children and let's assume you have a
very high income earner and um a spouse
who has had minimal income and so the
high income earner wants to create as
maximize income for the surviving spouse
um and the tension between that and the
children could you just talk more about
that because I'm confused you you
you I'm confused because obviously the
gror has to be alive when you make that
choice and so the gr tour is part of
this decision Mak process so I'm clear
on that but then I was confused about
transition of standard trust to a
unitary trust and how that works and
sure just walk me through that cluster
of issues totally totally understand so
let me let me start with the the uh
transition from an existing traditional
trust to a unit trust which is already
permitted under the statute that
requires notice first to all the
qualified beneficiaries of which in that
case the Widow would be a a recipient of
a notice and the trustee would say hey
I'm I'm thinking it's in your best
interest to go from a you from a
traditional trust where you're only
getting income to a unit trust where you
can you can share in the growth of the
trust and uh the Widow would then have
the option to say no I don't I don't
like that and then that squashes it
completely there's no they can't be uh
unilaterally forced into that structure
uh in in the event of a change from what
currently exists to to the new structure
they have to be they have to not object
to to that
um in in what we're trying to do in this
one is go I I'm sorry I just want to add
um because I mentioned Charities um in
any unit uh conversion to unit where
there was a charitable component there's
already requirements that the charitable
trust director be notified as well so
like the beneficiaries if there's a
charity involved and charitable trust
unit has the ability to go to court or
whatever they just object yeah yeah and
and in what we're to do here is just
provide another option for grant tours
when they're trying to devise uh their
estate plan essentially so uh in in the
in the panoply of options they have now
they could say I want to have my trust
uh for my spouse be uh completely
discretionary I want to name a trustee
might be the spouse might be a third
party trustee can make distributions in
any amount any time for any reason a
very broad full of discretion uh and
that's usually the case for first
marriages could be a second marriage
where you each have kids from different
from from prior marriages and you say I
want to benefit my spouse but I want to
make absolute sure that whatever is left
goes to my kids and doesn't go to some
future spouse or to my new spouse's kids
and so I want to Define what that
interest is that my spouse gets and
currently the optionality would be you
could you could have it' be an income
interest where you say my spouse should
get the income from the trust and my
kids get whatever is left over uh you
could say my spouse gets a dollar amount
you know she gets or he or she gets
$100,000 a year and that's it and then
everything that's left goes to my kids
what is not currently in there is the
concept of a percentage to say my spouse
should get and the the percentage that
we're targeting here is is 3 to 5% you
can get and as it as a comparison to the
income interest um so it's just to say
you get three to 5
% that's it and then and which allows
the trust to continue to grow you can
invest in grow stocks and you get to you
get to share in that growth and then
whatever's left over would go to the
kids um it's not a requirement it's just
we're just trying to add to the flexible
options that a that a grantor uh would
have when trying to determine what the
either in our case that we're talking
about here what the surviving spouse
would have and there's a lot of
literature if you Google this unitrust
uh there's a lot of literature on this
that uh shows that over uh the course of
at least American history the percentage
distribution standard results in a
better outcome both for that current
beneficiary which in our case would be
the spouse and the remainder
beneficiaries because investing for
growth has investing you know in America
essentially has has way outperformed
incom producing Investments and one
thing I would add is if you create a
unit trust under this uh under these
provisions unrea it would involve the
same kind of notice so whether you start
out with a traditional
trust revocable trust or you or you uh
start with a unit trust if you were
going to make that change it's the same
sort of a thing got notif my
beneficiaries so may other questions may
I just ask question so I'm on the uh so
if in the you know to use your example
of the like what would have been the
income beneficiary in the past will now
now be uh sort of a principal
beneficiary but only to a percentage of
the trust like let's say 3% or whatever
if
the I assume that you would then specify
in the trust when that percentage is
calculated in other words if you wanted
if you wanted the the former income
beneficiary now 3% beneficiary to get
that person's money next year um you say
that in the trust and then the rest of
it the other 97% if it was not going to
be distributed until later you'd say
that also that's exactly right and and
and the flexibility to Pivot within that
range 3 to 5% if you wanted to increase
or decrease that within the range it
would require notice uh and approval
essentially not objecting uh in order to
make that to make that tweak I see okay
and and you could just just to just
to kind of frame this uh differently if
in case this might help um
if the trust code generally speaking
gives a lot of discretion to set LS to
be able to craft their plans however
they want big picture um uh and so the
if you wanted to you know devise a plan
that said I want to
give a third of this trust to my wife in
year one a third the next year a third
the following you could do that what
this is really trying to do is say if
you're interested in the concept of
preserving principle for remainder
benefit fici Aries the the optionality
that you've had in the past has really
been income to this current beneficiary
or a dollar amount which they call like
an annuity interest this is saying in
addition to that you can devise that as
a percentage and that percentage is 3 to
5% if you're only trying to um create an
alternative to an income interest
preserving the principle for the
remainder beneficiaries down the road
and I should add the three to 5% is not
a um out of the air number
um in fact that under under current law
I think it says 5 to8 or something that
it has uh percentages that we believe
looking at some IRS viewpoints um might
not be uh H up in IRS scrutiny and 3 to5
is what we've seen in in IRS uh letter
rulings um we don't really know we've
tried to research why it had numbers
those numbers did not seem to come from
anywhere but New Hampshire um
uh and and and so but we we saw that
again more closely and said it would be
really helpful if trustees and settlers
could feel that what they're putting
together would hold up to to IRS you
know can you just enlight what what is
the explain the IRS implication okay so
so uh this gets a little technical but
um if you
um uh where do I start this so there is
a federal estate tax exemption amount
that every individual has that you can
pass on to non-spouse beneficiaries free
of estate taxes and currently it's a
huge number it's 13.6 one million per
person uh so a married couple gets
double that 13.6 times two um uh that
said if you have Assets in excess of
that amount and you'd be subject to
estate taxes on the death of the first
spouse one way to try to avoid estate
taxes at least on the death of first
spouse is to leave assets to your spouse
because there's an unlimited marital
deduction you can leave a trillion
dollars to your spouse on death and
there's no estate taxes on the first
death but if you say I don't really want
to leave it outright to my spouse for
the reasons we described before you're
fearful of a subsequent remarriage
you're fearful that this the sub the
second the spouse is going to leave it
to their kids and not your kids so you
want to leave it in a trust uh for the
benefit of that surviving spouse and
have that trust qualify for the
unlimited marital deduction that trust
has to have two features one is that the
surviving spouse has to be the sole
beneficiary no one else can benefit but
the surviving spouse and second at a
minimum the spouse has to have the right
to all of the income that the trust
generates in a given year and what the
unitrust statute the conversion statute
has tried to to thread the needle on is
to say we want to make sure that this
trust is still qualifying for that
unlimited meril deduction by giving a
mandatory interest to the surviving
spouse of income but defining that as a
percentage of the trust as opposed to
the dividends the interest on the bank
accounts and so on and so forth and so
the IRS has said 3 to 5% of the trust
Corpus is effectively the equivalent of
an income interest and they're okay with
that and so that's what we're trying to
tie
to yes representative
trip thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned that
uh whenever the trust is changed that
you have to notice the
beneficiaries uh what exactly do you
mean by that do you are you talking
about that it seems there's a couple
tiers of beneficiaries there's the the
uh spouse she's the primary beneficiary
Y and then you have you know uh whoever
else is uh identified in the trust their
secondary uh beneficiaries so do they
have to do you have to notify everyone
yes so the great great question so the
the technical term uh for the uh
permissible or the required people who
would receive notice is a qualified
beneficiary which has two tiers
qualified beneficiary means the person
who has the current right to receive
distributions from the trust and so in
the example we're been talking about
with a surviving spouse the spouse would
be that person and the person who would
receive the benefit from the trust if
that current beneficiary died and so
it's the first level of successor or
remainder beneficiaries that's what a
qualified beneficiary is you could go a
step further and say well if my If my
spouse dies and if that happened
everything went to the kids I'll notify
them and if all my kids and my spouse
died then maybe it goes to charity the
trust code does not require that next
level of beneficial interest to be part
of this because their interest is so
remote um uh so it's just first level
and second level and all of them have to
be given notice and in the statute it
gives them um a 60-day period uh to
object uh so they'd receive it they'd
have a period of time to object and if
they object then you can't do it and I'm
a wonky lawyer so I know that that that
is rooted in standing and whether that
person's interest uh is so remote As
Patrick put it that they would not have
standing to go out to court and assert
their interest it's
too representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I apologize for
being a few minutes late so I missed
Senator de los Sandra's presentation but
I think I've been here for all of
yours and um I have a question that
shows how little I
understand
where where does the
word
unitrust fit in where does that come
from oh so yeah great question so um no
it's not really a great question but
you're just polite no because there's
actually not a great answer for it so
it's you're you're you're addressing a
uh uh point that I've even questioned um
when defining a beneficial interest in a
trust or or maybe better said when
defining the uh distribution standard uh
that a trustee is responsible to carry
out in a trust um uh we Define them in
certain ways one is to say full
discretion truste has full discretion to
distribute as much as they want whenever
they want for whatever purpose second is
to Define it as an annuity to say that
the beneficiary has uh a cash a certain
dollar amount that they're entitled to
receive every year uh and the grantor
determines that 100,000 bucks 50,
whatever the number might be um uh the
third is an income interest which is
what we were describing before which is
you get the right to the income that the
trust generates in a given year and then
the fourth one is this unit trust why
it's called that I have no idea but it's
effectively trying to define the amount
that someone can get as a percentage uh
so you've got a dollar amount you've got
income you've got full discretion and
the unit trust why it's called that I
don't know but it's it's trying to get
at a percentage of the trust that is to
be distributed each
year thank you and how many States
um
have unit trust so um under the uh
uniform trust code which I think is
adopted in 30s something States roughly
uh they have the ability to convert an
existing trust to a unit trust so that's
very common um what is somewhat unique
uh in maybe a handful of states and
we're certainly aware of it in Delaware
which is one of the states that we're
competing against uh is the ability to
have a unit trust at Inception
um It's relatively A New Concept because
um the whole kind of legal industry
around unitrust has been conversion it's
taking these old trusts that are used to
this kind of clunky income interest and
making it more modernized and optimized
through a unitrust conversion uh there
just hasn't been much uh by way of um uh
thought leadership on doing it at
Inception and so that's uh we're we're
on kind of The Cutting Edge uh in trying
to do that but in a way we think is is
beneficial to everyone
involved and uh if I if I could
um does the trust unitrust or not have
to be established in the state residence
of the donor the the principal no so it
has to be it has to be created in New
Hampshire and so if you had somebody
that was a resident of New York and they
wanted to take Advantage they looked
around the country and said well which
state has the best laws in order for me
to achieve what I'm trying to accomplish
with my estate plan um they might not be
able to do it in New York so they'd have
to bring their trust to New Hampshire
and that's what we've been trying to do
over the last two decades and creating
an industry here uh that's created jobs
created Revenue to uh uh attract
people's trust uh here so is is this
playing um the Junior League Delaware
game is is that what this is I I don't
know what you mean by that Junior League
we're trying to be the best uh
jurisdiction and this is one of the
features that we think will make uh New
Hampshire attractive to uh outof State
grant tours to cite us their trust here
in New Hampshire and then just one last
if I have okay and uh do you have any
idea of um
what
revenue and exactly how that would be
measured I have no idea has come to the
state um
because of
this if I may looking at Patrick but
I'll be happy um I will be happy to send
you a couple of years ago and so it's
it's a little bit old but I we have only
grown as an industry since but a couple
of years ago there was a study committee
um kind of attached to a bill that was
passed that we we were supportive of and
we spent several sessions during during
the summer um and I had a economic study
uh done uh very conservative economic
study the original economic study for
trust modernization was a little bit um
effusive if you will but uh but I had a
very practical economics study done and
um there were something like 600 uh jobs
uh that are uh connected to the industry
um I I'll tell you this for scale when
uh trust monitorization began there were
probably around around $100 million of
trust Assets in New Hampshire and I'll
explain why that's important um the
banking department will tell you that as
at the middle of last year that was $1.3
trillion dollar um why that's important
is to have a New Hampshire a trust under
New Hampshire laws work uh in the way
that wherever the settlers from they
want it to work they typically need to
be administered in New Hampshire and so
that is how we've grown that industry um
and there are I think 35 now and growing
trust companies chartered in New
Hampshire but the total assets of 1.3
trillion is roughly twice South Dakota's
which is often thought of as the leading
state so I did want to just uh if I
might uh address the comment I think
Delaware's possibly sliding reputation
is not so much in their trust industry
as in their sort of
LLC we're the LLC State and I I lawyer
who works for me mentioned the other day
why are people not forming llc's in New
Hampshire we have much better LLC law
than Delaware but I think that that has
been you know a thing and the other
thing I'll say is these states we
compete with we're often I often get
calls from the Washington Post or others
what's going on there with there's all
this you know hidden money and all of
this
stuff the last time I spoke with them
the first thing they said to me was
we've looked at all these the latest one
was called Paradise papers and there are
no connections to New Hampshire trust
companies or New Hampshire Trustees of
course I said I could never promise you
that would be the case we're not you
know keepers of everyone but we've tried
to be both Innovative and conservative
and so our reputation is solid I would
say and and we're sort of often asked
why are you not in that group um you
know that sort of gets a negative
reputation we only want to be famous
among professionals who are trying to
steer their clients to sort of the best
approach and the best uh state to do it
in we don't want to be Infamous and then
I promise this is my last one so in
terms of this very impressive Revenue
figure that is revenue that goes to the
industry not to the state well that is
that is assets which is a kind of a
proxy measure of sort of the scale of
the industry the revenue that would come
to the state would be business profits
tax and I'm not privy to uh other
taxpayers uh business profits tax but
right even if you're not physically
located in New Hampshire if you are
doing New Hampshire trust administrative
work thank you very much for your
patience thank
you so you know I just I just have one
other question so this this amendment
that you I mean it's not in official
form but I'm going to submit um you've
gone through this line by line and it's
it it's right is that is that what we
think so okay all right all right cuz I
mean that's uh I how much more I you
know we all do our best we spent a lot
of time on it we've shown it to a lot of
people we do hope it is and we'll
certainly you know uh happy to look at
what comes back so you know what the
only other question I have is can you um
just to make it easy for me to submit
this as an amendment can you send me an
email copy of this yes so that I can
electronically then forward it to uh
actually I believe you have it but I'll
send it again just to be you don't mind
you have my email address yeah okay all
right representative Manos thank you Mr
chair and thank you again for taking my
questions um so I want to go back to the
unitary trust because I'm still puzzling
this through so the 3 to
5% I is that meant to equal an income
stream is that how it's derived and then
my qu my my other question
is um so would the would the
trustee let's say the distribution is
made as of December 31st and it and it
it's distributed on January
1st um would the trustee sell assets
that are worth 3 to 5% and then say to
the Widow here's your X number of
dollars yep or or do does the trustee
have to decide I'm going to send you
2,000 shares of Nvidia and and is it a
distribution of an asset or is it a
distribution of cash great question
great question yeah so um uh it can be
either uh and usually the beneficiary uh
is the one that informs what they want
the the trustee um the obligation there
is just to distribute value uh and so if
the whether that comes in the form of a
post sale proceeds and cash uh or if it
comes in the form of a distribution in
kind uh the trustee would be cloaked
with the power to do either but largely
it would be um uh uh in consultation
with the beneficiary to figure out what
they what they want the from a tax
perspective um uh on capital gain when
selling an asset whether it's sold
within the trust or sold uh in the hands
of the
beneficiary um uh from the federal
perspective there would be a non-issue
it's long-term capital gain is 20%
short-term capital gain is the same um
um regardless where there could be a
distinction H is uh
if you lived in a high tax jurisdiction
like California or New York or even now
Massachusetts uh and the trust is in New
Hampshire you might be better off
selling it in New Hampshire because
there's no income tax capital gains tax
here and then Distributing the proceeds
um on a taxfree basis so there could be
some optimization around state taxes
that would inform one way or the other
but there's no rigid requirement either
way um and I'm sorry I forgot the first
question first part of that that the 3
to 5% is yes yeah yeah so the 3 to 5% so
again with that is um I'll give you a
good example of kind of how this plays
out um if I'm if I'm trying to Define
what I want to leave to my spouse and
qualify that trust for the unlimited
meril deduction the IRS has said uh at a
at that the spouse has to have an income
interest they have to mandatorily be
required to receive distributions of
income and they're okay having that be
defined as 3 to 5% % of the trust but if
I'm if I'm the spouse and I say I'm the
deceased spouse I say I wanted to have
my spouse get um the income interest to
qualify it for the maril deduction 3 to
5 percent but in addition to that I want
um an independent truste to be able to
give distributions to my spouse in
excess of that totally fine totally fine
uh you could even say on on a much less
scale um I want my spouse to receive
three to 5% and my spouse is the bet is
the trustee and she or he can give as
much as they want to themselves on top
of that um uh so there's there's
complete flexibility to do more uh but
at a minimum in order to qualify the
trust for the marit deduction 3 to 5% is
the
floor yes represent thank you um the
other question I was um wondering about
do the REM remainder beneficiaries let's
say it's the Nvidia stock and and we
send the the spouse 20 shares do the
remainder beneficiaries have any right
to say no don't send her the Nvidia I I
want you to send her the Amazon nope no
no
power and just can I just ask one follow
question so the if the trust you know
uses to say 3 to 5% to the what would
have been the income beneficiary um and
it and that amount is to be
paid on a yearly basis let's say so is
so the first year the first year the
trust is worth the million dollars let's
say and they pay three to 5% the first
and then at the end of the second year
do you you revalue the trust as of that
year so if it's gone up to a million5
then it's 3% of a million5 yeah exactly
so so um for example for this year uh
you would look at December 31st value of
last year and then the grantor could
Define how frequently distribution
should be made so let's say that the the
percentage is four 4% and my math is
terrible let's just assume that as of
December 31st of last year 4% was
$100,000 just hypothetically um the
grantor could say I want that to be made
within the first 15 days of the year so
the spouse gets that money immediately
or the grantor could say I want that to
be paid monthly so you take that 100,000
divide it by 12 and it's paid monthly
you could do it quarterly you could do
it semiannually you can Define the
frequency but the value is as of
December 31st the prior year okay all
right other questions for yes
representative walls thank you chairman
Lyn um under that example uh the this
establishment of the unitrust actually
strikes a balance between the remainder
beneficiaries and the current income
beneficiaries while still
preserving principle by roughly having
that is dividing in two the
distributions on an annual basis so the
spouse would get a pro half of the
distributions the other half would
remain so that the uh principal would
grow further for the remainder
beneficiaries is would that be an
accurate assessment yeah the the only
the only um copy I'd say to that is if
the if the interest is 4% um that's what
they get there's no like half this half
that just that's what they get and and
the growth of this of the portfolio is
inuring not just to your point not just
to the remainder beneficiaries who are
getting a much bigger trust but in the
next year the spouse in that example is
going to get more
uh than if they were subject to you know
kind of a gradual grind of of of
dividend payments yes and that's going
to fluctuate because past uh gains are
not going to be indicative future
performance as we all
know right interesting any other
questions for these Witnesses all right
well thank you very much appreciate
thank you so much thank you thank you
all right is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on uh Senate Bill
435 right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on sen Bill
435 and um I think that's that's it for
us uh you know what can I um so we only
have we don't have all the bills in yet
but it looks like we might have two
other bills but I don't my sense is
let's just put it off for and does it
make the only other question is this
does it make any sense to come in next
week to exact what we have or just wait
wait wait that's fine I'm I'm fine with
that I we could use a week off
I'm good with that all right all
right that's it well what does
paragraph three 565b something say and
what does
it